this is amazing we got we got a bunch of
big news today so Twitter files 2.0 are
getting released and it's kind of more
of a supplemental metabe says apparently
James Baker former FBI involved in the
steel dossier The russiagate hoax the
fake impeachment against Donald Trump
was was was counsel for Twitter I think
he was what was he Deputy general
counsel or something and Elon Musk just
fired him this has to be the craziest
oversight so they're trying to release
the Twitter files evidence that the FBI
was involved in suppression of
information on Twitter there is a portal
for them to use on Twitter and Facebook
to manipulate and censor and information
when this guy is ousted from from the
FBI he eventually finds his way to
Twitter and then get this it was in 2018
that Joel Roth of Twitter said he got in
contact with the dni with DHS with FBI
and then sure enough this disgraced
establishment deep State FBI guy gets a
top lawyer position for Twitter and then
when they're trying to release the
documents this guy's jamming it up
it's just absolutely incredible so to
say that it was just you know the FBI
guiding not at this point when you've
got former disgraced FBI working as
counsel
in tandem with the FBI sensor
information come on don't play those
games with me when we see people at like
Monsanto or whatever Corporation
resigned and then get appointed to a
position in like the FDA or the federal
government we're like yeah no we get
what that's all about when say like a
high-ranking member of a company I don't
know Halliburton or something somehow
becomes what's a vice president or
something and then we go to work come on
so this is crazy and we got some other
news too we got uh Alex Jones giving
more information on what happened with
yay apparently he he was told they
weren't going to talk about this stuff
and they did anyway sounds very very
similar to what we're seeing here we'll
talk about that plus the story out of
Philadelphia where I think it's what is
a gas station where they got armed
guards with uh with some rifles now
because I'll say it again man I think
law enforcement doesn't exist what I
mean by that is of course there are
police of course there's the FBI but
they're not enforcing the law anymore I
don't know what they're doing it's
political or what we're seeing across
the board with like Katie Hobbs
certifying her own election the raw
exercise of power so we'll talk about
all of that before we get started head
over to timcast.com become a member to
support our work uh we had some issues
with the members only show yesterday it
was uh Chef Andrew girl he cooked this
amazing
omelette with like brussels sprouts but
uh it got fixed so that episode is up
we're gonna have another members only
show for you coming up tonight should be
a whole lot of spicy fun not so family
friendly so don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the share with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about all of
this is Savannah Hernandez thank you for
having me Tim I mean I for one am
completely shocked that our own FBI
would uh you know try to hamper the
truth about what's been going on at
Twitter from us our own FBI who could
imagine that they would be at the
Forefront of this shocking I mean
sincerely since the days of the
honorable J Edgar Hoover they've been
nothing but a proud American institution
so you're telling me you know based off
of these new Revelations that the FBI
doesn't have the American interests
public at the Forefront I'm truly
shocked I really am I didn't even know
how to you know properly assess what
we're seeing today but I guess we're
going to have to really delve into it
compose yourself it's shocking I know
but uh our own government being corrupt
I could never imagine you know Tim as
somebody who barely got reinstated on
Twitter after being permanently banned
for the past uh two years just two weeks
ago I for one am completely shocked at
our own government and Big Tuck would
try to censor the truth from the
American people insane so so what do you
do for those who don't know you
um for those that don't know me I am a
journalist who goes and covers uh
specifically like Progressive cities
here in the United States I like to do a
lot of man on the street work I go and I
talk to people on the ground you know
when um our beloved President Joe Biden
says that the economy is doing great
that we're flourishing that the gas
prices are lowering I love going and
speaking to Americans and asking them
hey what's actually going on in the
streets uh you know I've covered
extensively the NCAA Championship
earlier this year where Leah Thomas was
swimming and I was able to combat The
Narrative that it was a great thing that
Leah Thomas was swimming against females
you know I've broken stories regarding
black lives matter covered the riots
I've been focusing in a lot on drugs
crime and homelessness in Progressive
cities specifically democrat-run cities
to kind of highlight the reality of that
so that's a little bit of what I do
right on well thanks for hanging out
thanks for having me we also have Luke
wait until you guys find out about the
CIA there's there's oh yeah there's a
lot of things to talk about my name is
Luke radowski here I am your humble
t-shirt vendor today I'm wearing a
t-shirt that reads I am blank and and
ready to talk about politics at
Christmas if you want to find out what
blank is you will have to go to
thebestpoliticalshirts.com and because
you guys do that this is the main way
that you guys support me so thank you so
much for doing so and this should be a
great show thanks for coming Savannah hi
everyone Ian Crossland here happy to
rock and roll let's move this along
Serge tell me about it hey guys I'm at
serve.com good to see you again all
right let's get into that first story
from the New York Post Elon Musk fires
Twitter lawyer James Baker over Hunter
Biden's story suppression the funny
thing is you know if you just read the
headline you're like uh-huh why is that
news okay
Elon Musk fired Twitter general counsel
case it was just straight general
counsel wow in light of concerns about
Baker's possible role in suppression of
information important to the Public
Public dialogue he was exited from
Twitter today musk wrote on Twitter
Tuesday musk added that he questioned
Baker before his firing about the events
surrounding the laptop suppression uh
Scandal and that his explanation was
unconvincing Baker was previously
general counsel for the FBI under former
director James Comey and was a key
figure in the bureau's investigation
into false claims of collusion between
Russia and Donald Trump's 2016
presidential campaign full stop
the day I believe it was the day Donald
Trump was inaugurated a lawyer tweets we
are going to impeach you that lawyer
later went on to represent a client
whose name we won't say and then he uh
imp he was part of the impeachment
against Donald Trump there have been
people actively working against the
president and the American people since
2016. how this man comes to leave in
disgrace the FBI and then become general
counsel for Twitter it's very very
interesting especially when you take a
look at some of this other information
let me see if I can pull this up we have
Josh Holly there uh where do we have it
is it there we go America First legal
following the Twitter files AFL has been
obtained new documents uncovering a
secret Twitter portal U.S government
officials used to censor dissenting
covid-19 views and violate the First
Amendment so uh this is something more
than just in my opinion
the FBI advising Twitter giving giving a
humble warning to Mark Zuckerberg no
they had Direct access and they had some
of their loyalists inside the company
Matt taibi writes on Twitter
on Friday the first installment of the
Twitter files was published here we
expected to publish more over the
weekend many wondered why there was a
delay we can now tell you part of the
reason why on Tuesday Twitter Deputy
general counsel okay so it was Deputy
Jim Baker was fired among the reasons
vetting the first batch of Twitter files
without knowledge of New Management the
process for producing the Twitter files
involved delivery of two two uh two two
journalists Barry weissen me via a
lawyer close to New Management however
after the initial batch things became
complicated over the weekend while we
both dealt with obstacles to new
searches it was Barry Weiss who
discovered that the person in charge of
releasing the file was someone named Jim
when she called to ask Jim's last name
the answer came back Jim Baker my jaw
Hit the Floor says Weiss
look at this the first batch of files
both reporters received was marked
Spectra Baker emails maker is a
controversial figure he has been
something of a zelig of FBI
controversies dating back to 2016. from
the Steele dossier to the alpha server
mess he resigned in 2018 after an
investigation into leaks to the press
the news that Baker was reviewing the
Twitter file surprised everyone involved
to say the least new Twitter Chief Elon
Musk acted quickly to exit Baker Tuesday
reporters resumed searches through
Twitter files materials a lot of it
today the next installment of the
Twitter files will appear very uh at
Barry Weiss stay tuned
so how you guys doing
yeah I actually talked about this guy
yesterday
um and I brought up Jonathan turley's
article on him and he called them the
Kevin Bacon of the Russian collusion uh
Scandal the the story here is just
absolutely bewildering especially when
you look into the greater details this
guy was fired from the FBI for leaking
information on the Trump Administration
this guy was behind a lot of the major
warrants that were spying on the Donald
Trump campaign this guy then was working
with Vijaya Gotti one-on-one when it
came to censoring people in our
political landscape predominant people
who supported the Trump Administration
this guy's connected to the clintons
he's connected to James Comey he's
connected to almost virtually everyone
in the political sphere and Elon Musk
didn't even know he was working at
Twitter deciding what kind of documents
Barry Weiss and Matt taibi were getting
what that's how does that make sense it
does it does that make sense to you
absolutely not and you know what this is
just another great example too of just
how far the tentacles of our government
stretch in every aspect of our reality
and of our truth I mean going into again
big Tech which is one of the areas and
places where people cast their votes
where they gather their information
where their entire reality is dictated
essentially you have the FBI here
dictating reality dictating truth and
dictating what we're allowed to see so
you know even it's like our own
government right we instill somebody as
president who we think is going to
change things but then they have to go
through all of these other layers of
corruption and that's what we're seeing
right now with Twitter and all the other
you know people involved with even
suppressing the Twitter files it doesn't
surprise me that there was some deep
State act and when I say deep State I
mean like administrative State you know
I know very well that people will leave
the government you mentioned this
earlier Tim and then go work at Monsanto
or there'll be like a Monsanto Chief and
then they'll come work at the government
or they'll be like
it's just this revolving door of
government corporate collusion I just
have this is kind of the first time I've
seen it in social media yeah well
there's a saying once your CIA you're
always CIA to think to think that the
Federal Bureau of Investigations doesn't
have a similar role in our private
sector is foolish so I think it's fair
to say that the FBI has infiltrated many
big Tech social media companies whether
officially or unofficially and a lot of
the times it is them calling the shots
here and prove me wrong because there's
no other way to to see this from the
plethora of evidence that has been
provided to us
yeah I kind of just don't think that the
country exists anymore I saw you tweet
that earlier too what do you mean by
that I mean that um
the idea of the United States is now
this shell you know you can see the flag
but even the embassies flying a
different embassies are flying different
flags in some places not like flying on
the flagpole but they're putting up like
the pride flag and stuff like that you
go to a major city the attitude the
belief structure is so dramatically
different from people outside of cities
it's like just it's a clear distinction
here then you get to the courts
okay it's a league uh there's we call it
we call it illegal immigration for a
reason okay well a whole bunch of States
just completely ignore that law right
California for instance they call it a
sanctuary State you've got places like I
think New York and San Francisco were
doing this Upstate New York allowing
non-citizens to vote yeah now that these
court cases are going through look the
southern border is completely porous
non-citizens are voting what does that
even mean how is it a vote if people who
don't live here can change the way we
have to live then you have all of the
crime then you have this two things with
this that's why I say the US doesn't
exist anymore
you know I was I was talking about this
earlier with the um
some friends they're like don't you
think but this stuff's always been
happening and I'm like yeah you know
back in the day of J Edgar Hoover when
he's digging up dirt on presidential
candidates and stuff but you see the FBI
they were everywhere they had some there
was like some unified authoritarian
controller of this country now not only
can we see them doing it but we see them
doing it you know what I mean like we
know they do it and now we're watching
them do it meaning their control has
been completely subverted so there's
illicit activity going on from the the
federal government to try and control
things which they're failing to control
and then they're being exposed so not
only is there no seemingly functional
law enforcement if you look at what
happened with Marjorie Taylor green if
you look at what happens with us if you
look at what's happening with police
across the country and Security in
Philadelphia like you were mentioning
these armed guards outside the cops
can't do anything the FBI can't do
anything swattings are happening like
crazy two members of Congress and now
we're just sitting back literally
watching in real time the FBI fail to
pull off an infiltration wow and I think
think what we're seeing too right in the
modern days if you really take a step
back and look at it is that all of our
intelligence agencies have been
weaponized against the American people
and then you go to the Border like you
talked about Tim I've been to the Border
myself and I've watched the flood of
illegal immigration that happens every
single day I've talked to border patrol
who say uh we're essentially Uber for
the illegal immigrants at this point
there there's no stop to the flow there
we're essentially aiding and abetting
human trafficking at our border we're
aiding and abetting the cartel at this
point the Biden Administration might as
well be putting money directly in their
pockets because they are and so again
you know the border is an issue the
crimes an issue and then on top of all
of that our own intelligence agencies
are now attacking and uh you know
targeting the American citizen so I
completely agree with your sentiment
that the United States no longer exists
and it was funny too because so many on
the left were saying oh my gosh Donald
Trump called to abolish the Constitution
this is so horrific I can't believe he
would say something like that it's like
hold on you guys impede on our first
amendment rights and our Second
Amendment rights every single day we
just had Joe Biden the other week saying
we need to ban assault weapons every
single day you have the Democrats trying
to take away our our Second Amendment
right our ability to defend ourselves to
keep us from becoming New Zealand China
or Australia and you're mad because
Donald Trump said something about
abolishing the constitution on true
social get you know give me important
say that he's like some rules including
some of those in the Constitution may
have to be suspended or Terminators I
think Terminator is what he said so he
didn't come out and say like terminate
the entire Constitution he was like some
of these rules have to be terminated
okay not a fan not a fan of when Abraham
Lincoln did it but Abraham Lincoln did
it too just saying I get the vibe that
the internet has changed the way Nations
govern themselves so drastically this
internet video and things like that now
like the the cohesion of
um the the myth of what we are used to
be through ABC NBC CBS and they were
told to you and that was the
administrative State now now everyone
it's it's Madness it's Madness and
Nations I think rightfully so are
dissipating like the idea that we that
the United States and ends at that drawn
out line is ridiculous now those people
on the other side like the cartels you
mentioned are just as much a part of
this system as I am whether I want it to
be or not we're all in this together so
it's it's it's faltering I don't think
that it means that the American ideals
are disappearing I think that the
Constitution and the idea is that it
represents are fantastic and could be
globally adopted you know you see
revolution in China with Ian the fact
that our own press secretary has the
audacity to get up in front of the
American people every single day and lie
to us boldface you know this
Administration tried to change the
definition of recession as we were
actively going through it this entire
Administration tries to pretend that the
economy isn't failing that inflation
isn't at a 40-year high the fact that
our own government is not fearful of the
American people and and you know they're
willing to lie to us so both fees it
really pisses me off and I think it goes
to show that yeah we don't have the
country that we once had you know Jack
busovic always loves to tweet that out
that the America that we once knew no
longer exists and I completely agree
with that sentiment because think about
the fact you that we're raising an
entire generation that thinks that this
type of government is normal that
changing the definition of things is
normal I was thinking about the fact
that TSA right I thought that that was a
normal thing I wasn't aware that taking
off your shoes getting frisked by the
TSA was not a normal part of modern day
Society think about the fact that gen Z
is going to think that face masks that
government overreach that the
government's spying on you that the
government lying to you and redefining
our modern day language is just how
Society has always run let me I'll make
a point to the uh country no longer
existing too there are a lot of people
that still believe in the United States
and they're holding to this idea on this
Vision I respect that I I like what
America represents I like the
Constitution but come on take a look at
the Constitution take a look at the Bill
of Rights is the federal government
abiding by the Bill of Rights let's
let's go through it the first amendment
what did we just learn okay well the FBI
the DHS dni are colluding with big Tech
platforms to censor legitimate legal
speech major political parties like the
DN C which includes public officials are
actively suppressing speech and we can
see it's happening in California we can
see it from the Missouri lawsuit that's
that's the first amendment is gone
Second Amendment oh I don't even got to
talk about that come on Democrats are
trying to ban semi-automatic weapons
third amendment I got you there baby
during coven they were mandated that you
couldn't evict people and that meant
this is hilarious by the way that active
duty soldiers military personnel who are
currently living as tenants in in
property they could not be evicted and I
gotta say that literally violates the
third amendment the third amendment of
course most people don't realize is you
the government can't quarter soldiers in
your home so the argument was actually
made Fourth Amendment oh come on the
fourth has that one existed for a long
time NSA lying to Congress they've bulk
spying all of that stuff tapping the
deepsea cables come on those are the
first four that are gone how about the
Fifth Amendment oh boy you want to go
through this one January 6th defendants
how long have they been locked up
without charge without without trials in
solitary confinement I get edit the list
goes on there's no there's no right to
confront your accuser there's no speedy
trial let's talk about the 9th and Tenth
Amendment oh boy do we got to go there
look
you've got the fracturing across the
board of the Constitution it's just
non-existent sorry to say when you
brought up Trump I was going to make a
joke I was like we have a constitution
here but but you've made the point a lot
more clearer by going through each of
the Amendments here and yeah which one's
the seventh is that is that the one
about suing someone for 20 bucks or is
it which one is that one I don't know
I'm gonna I'm gonna look it up right now
but but there is something to say about
you know Rogue intelligence states that
have pretty much just destroyed
conversations destroyed speech destroyed
people's ability to to just have a fair
political system it what's happening
right now is not fair what's happening
right now is not just it's it's one
party consolidating enough power and
authority for themselves to do whatever
they want trying to create a Chinese
style totalitarian Society where they
try to disarm you put you on a social
credit score as you're going to be
living through a central bank digital
currency asking for permission just to
do anything in your life as of course
the richest most powerful people or only
setting policies that are making them
more richer and more powerful than ever
the last few years we have seen the
largest transfer of wealth in I think
recorded human history that is something
worth noting when it comes to robbing
people of any kind of ability not only
to to fight back but to live a life that
that ability has been Stripped Away from
a lot of decent hard-working Americans
that could no longer make ends meet
could no longer act by a society that
that is acting by Fair rules because
it's not everywhere you go there is some
kind of uh nonsense out of some kind of
woke policy there's some kind of bull
crap out there that just robs you of a
good fair and honest living Lucy and I
always make the argument as well because
we're constantly talking against the
world economic Forum George Soros a lot
of these like you'll own nothing in be
happy policies right but we're
essentially already living through that
do we truly own anything if you pay off
your house do you truly own your house
are you still paying property taxes to
the government do you truly have a
constitution do you truly have freedom
of the press and the United States of
America or is Big Tech going to like the
New York Post story with Hunter Biden
kind of censor and suppress what you're
really allowed to say ahead of a uh you
know important election I'm not sure so
you know we have to ask these very
important questions because people are
consistently warning against these
things a warning against this
totalitarian state the authoritarian
government but I for one think that
we're essentially already living through
it and we essentially have this illusion
that we're not but I don't think we're
really free in the United States uh
unfortunately anymore I want to pull up
this uh Twitter thread we briefly uh
went over before it's from America First
legal and just we'll go through this
they say following the Twitter files
America First legal has obtained new
documents uncovering a secret Twitter
portal U.S government officials used to
censor dissenting covid-19 views and
violate the First Amendment follow along
they say this is what 500 500 plus page
release in August of 2021 the head of
Google's news lab for the Asia Pacific
region APAC emailed a CDC vaccine
confidence strategies to an invited to
the Apex trusted media Summit cdc's
vaccine confident strategist then
emailed the event planner for Google's
APAC trusted media Summit noting her
excitement over being invited to what
she referred to as the coolest
misinformation fighting Speakeasy I
don't want to go through every single uh
every single element of this but I want
to highlight and then we'll go through
this the fact that it's not just Twitter
okay YouTube obviously I love this one
YouTube has rules on what you can and
can't say about vaccination and covet
here's the funny thing those rules have
dramatically changed over time is that
YouTube accepting responsibility for
false information for posting
misinformation now YouTube can argue we
were only fighting following the
guidance from officials well now we
actually have some testimony from some
of these officials that they actually
based their decisions off nothing so
here's what we have
the government it's not it's not just
factory setting guidelines it is the the
federal exec the executive branch with
direct access to Facebook to Twitter to
YouTube to censor information they don't
like often with zero Merit
and where's that bring us
including satire including humor
including legal political speech that
couldn't be in the public discourse
because some politicians some fat cat
bureaucrat some some Karen Becky said I
don't like this speech I'm going to
censor it that that's the the idea that
a politician could say those ideas
shouldn't be in your mind is is like
Peak orwellian Peak tyrannical it's
something that we should push back
immediately because these people are
essentially trying to push thought
control mind control on the general
public and there's no other way of
arguing it I don't see it any other way
we we used to talk about how in the
United States you could mock your
political leaders you know it's one of
the few countries in the world where you
can make fun of your present all that
stuff you still can't to a certain
degree but when people went online and
made fun of fauci the government
intervened and got these people banned
well not only that but remember that The
Intercept just put out that article as
well about the DHS and the
disinformation governance board and how
they were trying to essentially censor
speech regarding the withdrawal of
Afghanistan racism and social Justice or
racial Justice I'm sorry and then again
of course covid-19 as well so going back
to that freedom of speech do we really
have the ability to question our
government officials like we talked
about with Twitter they have backtracked
on a lot of their covid-19 policy I for
one almost lost my entire YouTube
channel because I was reporting what the
own CDC was saying to us and then you
know highlighting the hypocrisy of um
how they were kind of going back and
forth with things I got censored for
that multiple times
they did that to Crowder Crowder got a
strike for just reporting what the CDC
was saying yeah yeah that was a fun time
the past two years have been a lot of
fun on big Tech yeah yeah let me let me
pull this real quick uh sorry but
Michael Tracy says Joel Roth said he had
weekly meetings with FBI DHS Etc
throughout 2020. let me stress this he
writes where is he since 2018 I've had
regular meetings at the office of
Director of National Intelligence
Department of Homeland Security the FBI
and Industry peers during these meetings
they said blah blah blah hacked
materials about Hunter Biden here's what
we know
was the FBI directing Twitter to take
things down hmm it appears not
but there was a former FBI agent who got
hired by Twitter who was working
alongside the FBI and then taking things
down so let's just be for real was the
FBI directly doing it any sane person
would say yes to think that like this
guy's ousted from the FBI goes work to
Twitter then keeps talking to the FBI
about how to operate and it's not the
FBI pulling the strings spare me Tim
honestly I'm at the point where I'm like
uh put the FBI in the same category as
the ATF and the CIA abolish all of them
because I truly haven't seen anything
good come of the FBI is this the same
FBI that's been in trapping Americans
for you know probably since it's
Inception I I don't know what good has
come out of the FBI because maybe I'm
just misinformed on this The X-Files
that show is awesome they also you know
arrested peaceful preachers at abortion
clinics very true very thank you to the
FBI for talking they were singing they
were singing the hymns very aggressively
well look you guys know that silent
prayer is violence yeah absolutely like
those thoughts those can hurt people
honestly being you know having
dissenting views in 2022 is violence
this room is violence I can feel it
emanating okay
what was uh oh yeah Colin told probe
definitely something worthwhile to doing
definitely something that was honorable
and not deceitful and not working in
secret in order to cause chaos within
political movements I've gone to the
point in my career with politics where
sometimes I just don't even want to look
back historically at what our government
and what our intelligence agencies have
done to us and done to the American
people because it's just black pills me
to no end I'm like okay so the CIA is
the one that brought LSD and crack to
the American public got it the FBI is
the one who's been entrapping Americans
for the past couple of years and they
were directly tied to January 6th got it
don't forget about funding cartels and
terrorist organizations and Isis was
fast and furious uh no no Fast and
Furious was uh I think uh yeah DEA you
look at any of our intelligence agencies
um project Veritas just came out with
their own expose about the HHS and I was
reporting on NVM mink earlier this year
about how essentially we're trafficking
children via taxpayer per dollar dollars
you know utilizing the cartel the Border
everything going on over there our
government complicit in all of it we're
paying for child trafficking trafficking
for crying out loud and um yeah
everyone's just kind of okay the FBI is
not that bad they did a really good job
protecting Epstein for 30 years so true
yeah they made sure that he was able to
continue his operations when when the
victims and the children were coming
forward they made sure to shut them up
but they did a great job at that in the
90s yeah so this is the point that I was
making about the US like there was a
period where their their power was kind
of absolute you know that that stuff
they were doing that was America no we
didn't like it of course and then you're
a conspiracy there's if you thought it
but think about where we are now it used
to be that if you came out and said
there was a cabal of wealthy Elites who
are trafficking children using a private
island a bit Yeah crazy and now it's a
definitive fact like Maxwell's literally
in prison for this Epstein is no longer
living now it's like you asked Bill
Clinton about it and it's like please
baby please do do not question him about
that okay nobody needs to question Joe
Biden about these things either if it's
not not on the approved media question
list we're just going to go ahead and
overload you know maybe I should put
this another way maybe it's wrong to say
there's no us anymore maybe for a period
there wasn't one maybe this corrupt deep
State controlling things was when the
U.S was suppressed and what we're seeing
now with us calling it out and and
pointing it out exposing the corruption
and stopping it is the Resurgence of
America Tim I've been looking into the
Council on Foreign Relations and how
they've had Direct ties to you know our
upper officials in government and media
exactly in the corporate world again
this just goes back to me being super
black pill because you read about all of
these groups that have had ties to who
is allowed to be in our government and
it's this entire illusion of choice so I
do agree with that sentiment a little
bit more where it's like well maybe
things have always been this way we're
just seeing it now and open uh because
we have you know Freedom of Information
via the big text some what to see this
maybe it's always been this way yeah
Tulsi gabbard also a member of the
Council on Foreign Relations a group
started by and David Rockefeller that
has codified a lot of the secretive not
secretive meetings in institutions that
they have had within our National
Security State and the corporate banking
world as well instituting their policies
covertly and also uh publicly as well
the larger point that I really wanted to
make about this and I'm so happy you
brought up the Council on Foreign
Relations this is like the topic that I
love love to especially talk about they
banned me uh from from their facilities
uh previously they're doing something
right but this is exactly how they work
it's a revolving door between a lot of
people with government in the private
world and the private world and to think
that that you know their their
accomplishments that their you know job
leaves when they leave that physical
office is is again a misnomer they're
all interconnected they're all dating
each other they're all related to each
other they're all going to the same
parties they're all doing the same drugs
they're all doing unspeakable things
that I can't even mention here on this
broadcast in Twitter and there and and
they also run larger extortion
operations on each other to keep each
other in check so this this power grid
system has many different layers to it
and I think we're seeing some people are
arguing that you know maybe things
aren't getting worse maybe we're just
finding out about what they really are
um and and I I think that's an aspect
that I think we should be considering
here are we finding out more and
realizing the truth of this world that
was hidden from us before or is it
really getting that bad what are you
guys we're finding out more about what
has always been but it's also a set of
new challenges right now we need to
protect our constitutional rights as
American citizens so we have encryption
to protect our First Amendment right you
have decentralization to protect your
First Amendment right because
centralized systems are vulnerable you
have ghost guns you have the ability to
3D print weapons to protect your second
Amendment right like you can't rely on
some external Force to protect your
rights those are your rights and we need
to work together to protect our rights
as Citizens Luke and I'm so glad that
you said that because what I have
realized is Ian well Luke sorry you're
both white men you guys look exactly the
same
um
how can you what do you mean looks a
person of color exactly I apologize can
I say what can I say you know you know
that Slavic people are people of color
right yeah I do now I'm sorry I just
told you I'm a bigot one more apology
and it's okay before we get to real tell
me what I was saying was right again
what were you what were we what were you
just talking about oh so yeah
so the mass is what I have realized now
going out uh you know Across America
because for the past six to seven months
I really have dedicated my life to going
to the Bronx Skid Row Portland
Kensington Avenue in Philadelphia
because I have wanted to see what has
been going on in these cities and I have
wanted to see what the American public
has been experiencing but I realized
that the masses and you know the
majority of people genuinely do need
somebody to think for them
and that's why it has been so easy for
our government to just come in and take
over do something like this we all see
it in plain sight and everyone's just
like okay oh well the government is you
know kind of subverting the Democracy
whatever it is what it is
um
it's so rare to have people who are
original thinkers and willing to stand
up for themselves and I think people
like Tim Poole are going to come save
them they think people like Donald Trump
are going to come save them no people
have to go and stand up for their own
rights and freedoms you have to be the
one to make the change and you have to
get rid of that mentality of oh well
someone else will do it for me someone
else will say this for me like no you
have to be the one who gets active in
your community and makes the change
because that's why America has gotten to
where it currently is is because of weak
men weak women and weak-willed people
who refuse to actually stand up and
speak out against everything some people
would say we are changed but also I want
to make a correction here it wasn't the
DEA between uh that was behind Fast and
Furious it was the ATF so just uh yeah
just the correction there our other
favorites the ATS yeah yeah I gotta say
like the DEA shouldn't exist the ATF
shouldn't exist and at this point
neither should the FBI so but like you
know to be honest like the DEA and the
ATF are like top contenders because like
the DEA
I need I just yeah I'm sorry oh yeah
marijuana schedule one right there's so
much broken stuff about this the atf's
weird because like what is Firearms have
anything to do with tobacco like what
the hell those are completely different
organizations yeah yeah let's let's jump
to this story we have this uh tweet from
Jason Martinez he says a North Philly
owner says he's had enough violent crime
at his gas station so he's hired these
guys to protect his customers in store
does this make you feel safer or
uncomfortable uh let me just say I will
show you this this guy right here he's
got a mask on he's got what looks like
an AR pistol I think it's a Glock mag so
probably not with nine millimeter and uh
you take a look at what we got here
there's another guy here this this fella
over here what does he got he's got I'm
not sure you guys you guys probably know
better than me is that a Bullpup 12
gauge uh no probably not probably not I
don't know what that is it's a Bullpup
something or other but I gotta be honest
I feel a whole lot safer at those guys
standing around I'm going to get gas and
there's two dudes with rifles I'm gonna
feel pretty good you know better than if
they weren't there situations that's
that's true and I also am like okay it's
better than no security but that is the
slippery slope of private security is at
first it feels good because it's better
than none but then all of a sudden
there's going to be six guys then
there's 14 guys then a corporation comes
in and is running the show then the
owner of the corporation decides now
this gas station's my gas station and
who's there to stop them so like you got
to be real careful with private security
you're describing governments Ian yeah
some people someone said bulb up 556
someone said Bullpup 12 gauge
uh I'm not sure I think it's a 12 gauge
I thought I thought it was a shotgun
yeah 12 gauge Bullpup shotgun and then
that's obviously a Glock mag in there
yes so it's like an AR pistol or
whatever what's you you were in Philly
right do you see this stuff going on I
was in Philly three weeks ago I didn't
see this type of stuff going on but what
I did see on the streets of Philly was
absolutely horrific now for viewers who
aren't familiar with me again I have
reported in the Bronx on Skid Row in
Portland in the course of two hours of
reporting on Portland I watched a man
overdose in front of me and a woman's
store get robbed I immediately went and
I interviewed the business owner and she
said oh this happens two to three times
a day I interviewed a police officer as
the guy was overdosing he says oh this
happens three to four times a day it's
not a big deal during the summer uh
we'll have four to five overdoses within
the course of one block at the same time
not a big deal going to Philadelphia was
probably one of the most horrific places
I have ever reported on it was
terrifying and I completely understand
the need to have this type of private
security when I was in Philadelphia I
was reporting on their needle exchange
program gram I was assaulted for
reporting on a public Street and my
equipment smashed I was slapped in the
face I had urine splashed on me my
friend was calling the police to which I
laughed and responded why are you
calling the police they don't exist here
you think the cops are going to come and
care that I got slapped in the face you
have people getting executed on the
streets in Philly my friend actually
sent me a video just the other day the
exact location I was reporting in a
security guard shot in the back of the
head execution style in the exact place
that I was that's what's happening on
the Streets of Philadelphia every single
day the police do not exist there the
police do not exist in Portland where
back in 2020 they decriminalized hard
drugs and you can go shoot up heroin in
front of a police officer in Los Angeles
in San Francisco in Portland Oregon the
police don't exist in these areas so I
completely understand uh you know these
private security members being hired
take a look at this right here so a
couple people have said 100 12 gauge
some people have said Bullpup 556. it uh
it looks like a Tavor 12 gauge Bullpup
is that what it is because it looks very
much like one that I have and I'm
looking at that Barrel what do you think
Luke well there's a Trevor
um 556 but I don't think that's it
um I think it's it's a it's a Bullpup
yeah I don't know who makes it and
produces it I've got one I got a Bullpup
shotgun looks just like that yeah yeah
that makes more sense to me
but yeah what's the accurate range on
that thing well it depends what you're
shooting would you classify that as an
assault rifle they do it looks very
scary they they assault like they they
assault shotgun assault shot yeah of
course absolutely like if it has a
pistol grip and a rifle and a rifle
stock it's an assault the good thing tin
is um you know all this gas station
really had to do was say this is a
gun-free zone and then the criminals
wouldn't go and attack them so it's kind
of their own fault for not putting up
that sign because we all know that
that's the most simplistic way to stop
crying by screaming please don't yeah
that's worked throughout the year this
is a gun-free zone the Karma's like oh
my bad it stopped Genghis Khan actually
wait no it didn't nothing stopped it's
also important to know Ian times time so
it's a beautiful wife while this is
happening in Pennsylvania in places like
New York City they're spending uh
government resources there going up in
Times Square and making sure to notify
people that they cannot legally carry
arms and that Times Square is a gun-free
zone essentially saying hey criminals if
you do have a gun which most criminals
you do during during this crazy day and
age and they don't follow the gun laws
that if they have any victims there the
victims won't be able to defend
themselves that's essentially what
they're saying that's essentially what
they're doing at least Pennsylvania
there is still as of right now some kind
of semblance of ability of human beings
to be able to defend themselves and
sadly we're going towards a society
where if you have money you could have
protection you could have security if
you don't have money you're screwed you
know what my favorite thing is is when
politicians like ilhan Omar who call to
abolish the police are then surrounded
by private security oh yeah I always
love to see it I grew up with this in
Chicago all these politicians would be
alive guns should be banned and then
they're allowed to carry guns
politicians and then and not only that
they have the rich people the the
wealthy Democrat types voting for the
stuff have armed guards it's like uh you
know when the Pelosi's were shocked that
a crazed crackhead in San Francisco
broke into their home it's like
congratulations that's what happens to
the people of San Francisco every day
you're not special you talking about
that dude that apparently hit Paul
Pelosi with a hammer I feel like they're
they're railroading that guy like I
think Paul knew that guy in their room
he's claiming his innocent yeah he said
he was innocent Paul was smiling and
laughing interesting story you know I
heard that security guard you mentioned
that got X you thought got executed and
I heard he survived oh God execution
style okay yeah but I think he survived
as well good came up on this on the show
a little while ago yeah I wonder if like
I don't know I I think I think like
Media Matters wrote something about we
were talking about the Paul Pelosi
attack and they wrote some nonsense
where it's like they believe weird
conspiracies and I was like the whole
segment was that we didn't know what
really happened because the police keep
changing their story but if you in any
way question the narrative that means
you're a conspiracy theorist it's like
bro I don't have a theory I was like the
police changed their story we don't know
what happened my favorite thing was when
what was it MSNBC or NBC uh suspended
their own reporter for accidentally
telling the truth about that story all
right he's still gone he's still
suspended to tell the truth on a
mainstream don't do it don't do it guys
could you imagine like you're a reporter
and you get a email it's like come to
the come to HR and they're like
yeah um Miguel we have troubling
reporting coming in from co-workers did
you tell the truth on air well I I I did
I'm sorry you know but thank you for
being honest or or not you're suspended
it's like look it specifically says on
line four of your contract that you're
not supposed to tell the truth so you're
gonna have to get fired sorry sorry my
guy they like they throw they have like
a sarlacc pit and they're like at least
push them in dude that's our media it's
like how you know Amy Robuck is
currently in the news right now for
having an affair with one of her
co-hosts but she wasn't in the news back
in what two years ago when she knew
about Jeffrey Epstein and kind of just
overlooked it really it's amazing well
let's break that down I mean you get uh
this she gets she gets booted I think it
was Daily Mail that found out that so
this is an ABC news anchor her and her
co-host were like hooking up and I think
like they got a photo of him smacking
her butt or something yeah so they take
her off the air yeah but when she got
caught when she was on a hot mic and
camera talking about how they had the
Epstein story and veritas releases this
they're alive how she had the clintons
how she had victims coming forward how
she had to feel horrible after
interviewing having these women trust
her to do this story and then let them
down because some executive at ABC said
no we're going to be protecting this
larger child trafficking and extortion
operation which is being protected by
the intelligence agencies come on but
enough here is where we draw the line
yes can't do that can't do that
absolutely disgusting society that that
again has a lot of hypocrisy in it and
if you and and this is what we know
imagine what we don't know imagine all
the things that are happening behind the
scenes that we that are still being done
in secret that it's still uh unknown to
the general public you can only imagine
how more debaterous how more insane
things get dude the fact that we saw the
entire Balenciaga campaign just you know
out and open to the public it's like I
don't know if I want to know what we
don't know I'd rather know
um I have my I have my theories I I like
to talk about some of these theories but
uh I I can't sometimes on YouTube are
they are they conspiracy theories
um I think the conspiracy theories now
are spoiler alert uh for the general
public because when we look at what's
been happening in the last few years I
mean it's just time after time the the
whole agenda the whole narrative has
been collapsing everything that they try
to shove down our throat everything that
they're trying to tell us is lies and
and it's all being unraveled every
single day it's crazy remember when Alex
Jones went on Rogan and talked about
like multi-dimensional beings cell
towers hybrids I'm just like at this
point I'm I have I have very little
doubt left in me now I'm kind of just
like you know I don't know dude if
Hillary Clinton shed her skin on camera
and became a lizard person I'd be like
I'm not surprised I get it
another penny in the eyelids
blinks like her eyes go like that you
know you're just like yeah old news we
already knew her tongue comes out Elixir
eye you're like uh-huh picks up the
loogie she puts in her glass
you know what they're doing it for it's
so that when the aliens land we go
uh-huh we get it just land which they've
already been releasing these documents
like oh the government has been uh
talking to FB or alien you know entities
for years and everyone's like cool
yeah proof is I'll believe it when I see
it even then I probably won't believe it
no I think the opposite I'd like an
alien walk up to me and be like I'm
sorry I have no doubt left in me you
know what I mean like so much weird
stuff has happened over the past few
years Tim would be like he's taking me
away please God I mean it depends if it
was like the Federation and they were
like we're gonna leave Earth and it's
Petty nonsense but no what I mean is
like it would be over in the news cycle
within a week oh Hillary Clinton
shape-shifted next week Donald Trump
wants to end the Constitution next week
and some other exactly it bumps you know
again it literally would be just a blip
in in our headlines in the way we're
consuming news it would be page 20 of
like the New York Times and it would be
like a small paragraph like earlier
today Hillary Clinton was revealed to be
a shape-shifting lizard person after
shedding her skin during a campaign run
and it would not even be front page
front page would be like Jim Jim Bob
from West Virginia suspected of being
January 6 Capital rioter front page or
some woke stupid idea about some kind of
actor portrayals or racism or other
Men In Black where they have the
tabloids and they're telling the truth
about what's really going on about the
aliens or whatever and everyone's like
yeah whatever it's fake news that's just
our modern day now I'll just watch this
point is that we're making jokes about
like how shocking it would be if Hillary
Clinton shed her skin we have the Super
Chat from third eye sag who says kind of
like how Cuomo got pushed out of office
over a sex scandal uh instead of
murdering 15 000 people yup yeah yeah
well I mean why was the government
attack him for that they do that every
single day you know yeah they're
probably sitting around and they're like
well the public is pretty mad that Cuomo
killed 15 000 people but we don't want
to come down on them because what if we
want to kill 15 000 people later yeah
I'm surprised he didn't get a Noble
Peace Prize for that well actually we
asked you to do 30 000 so you came under
par but that's why they actually got him
out yeah they were like we're not gonna
get you out of office for the 15 000.
but you did come in underperforming so
we're gonna use a sex scandal to fire
you we instituted you for depopulation
and you failed so you're fired have fun
that's the crazy that's that's just the
craziest thing you know looking at the
Canadian euthanasia stuff I was looking
at that today it was like Die With Honor
dignity or something oh yeah they're
saying the media tries to come out these
these corporate journalists and say like
there's no depopulation agenda and it's
like what do you think what is it called
when Bill Gates goes on stage at a Ted
conference and says if we work really
hard we can reduce global population
growth by 15 that's population reduction
that's a depopulation agenda like I
don't understand how that's not a thing
when the dude went on stage at Ted and
said it it's a population retardation
meaning a slowing of the growth of the
population it's not really a reduction
it's more of a sloth everything coming
out of Canada right now is absolutely
insane though I believe I was reading a
story about this 23 year old who had
diabetes in the Canadian government's
response was die yeah that's basically
it now that's our health care System you
should probably just die you know
regarding this government the problems
people have been having with the
government I don't I don't really I'm
confused right now I see the liberal
economic order this is my when I say our
government I consider it the liberal
economic order it's well established
George Bush Senior established it's
transitioning to a new world order it's
a global order now why would they the
liberal economic order go to odds with
Russia when we're trying to create
Global governance in our image why would
we stifle and alienate one of our
greatest potential allies because they
won't bend the knee you need conflict
but Russia and Vladimir Putin have made
statements saying that specifically they
want to be a part of the New World Order
they want to have a seat at the table
and the United States and other Western
powers are saying no everything's from
us at the table Rush is saying we just
want to sit there but the reality is
brics China is just as much as part of
this as the liberal economic or the
brics order so like why are we not vying
for Russian uh let me tell you from CNN
Putin's signs expanded anti-lgbtq laws
in Russia and latest Crackdown on rights
I was just about to say is that what
they're calling it on so the new laws
make it illegal to promote or praise
lgbtq relationships publicly expressed
non-heterosexual orientations or suggest
that they are normal the package of
amendments signed by Putin include
heavier penalties for anyone promoting
additional sexual relations and or
preferences as well as pedophilia and
gender transition under the new law it
will be banned across the internet media
books audio visual Services Cinema and
advertising
so Ian was just asking why the U.S is
trying to go to war with Russia well the
U.S is very much in favor of all of
these things and Russia opposes them
well I think it's not just like that I I
think when we look at examples like
Saudi Arabia they commit far more
atrocious things than what happens in
Russia and they're far far more as a
bigger cultural difference with Saudi
Arabia than Russia I I think it's even
deeper than this there's another article
by Fox News that I think is worth
pulling up and it's titled Wall Street
CEOs funding China's military and human
rights abuses here's why and when we
look at the rise of China it is partly
responsible because of many Western
Elites the Rockefellers Henry Kissinger
and of course a lot of the foreign
policy that shipped American jobs and
labor overseas so there is an effort to
globalize the world but more importantly
control the world and in China you see a
lot of very powerful billionaires in
America financing that movement you see
Bill Gates you see Klaus Schwab saying
they're doing great work when they're
locking people inside of their homes and
there's fires there there and literally
people die because of these fires now
now when we when we see that when we
look at this covid zero policy these are
policies that a lot of people want to
implement all over the world so why is
Russia at odds here and China isn't well
that should be something that should
have a lot of people thinking what's
really going on here because it's not
just cultural differences I think
there's a bigger agenda trying to make
China a perfect example for the rest of
the world I think that's what they're
going after I think that's that's what
they're trying what's the situation with
the Chinese riots Revolution I mean it
looks like people all across the country
were stepping up and in crowds and like
overthrowing the government I mean it
looks like that's what they're
attempting to do what's going on there
that's what I was seeing uh I mean I saw
that Klaus Schwab said that the Chinese
model you know needed to be implemented
everywhere else and then the Chinese
people themselves were pushing back
because yeah they're dying in these
fires they're still being
um locked up by their government they
have their QR codes that dictate where
they can travel if they can leave or not
so yeah as far as I'm concerned the
Chinese are still pushing back
um I'm not sure we all know that it's
very difficult to see what's actually
happening on the ground yeah it's very
hard to verify all the news coming from
there because there's there there are
some reports saying that the Chinese
government is getting rid of
restrictions getting rid of some
lockdowns and allowing people to
quarantine inside of their own homes but
there's also more video footage of
police officers and these you know white
hooded crazy individuals busting down
doors and asking and demanding people's
cell phones so they could go through all
the data making sure that they didn't
they didn't share anything through
Bluetooth
um and and also airdrop yeah yeah
airdrop which uh you know Apple isn't a
big fan of and has stopped in China very
interestingly uh the same Apple that of
course makes very Grand statements about
George Floyd here domestically and makes
very big statements about Injustice here
domestically but uh doesn't seem to
really care about it when it's uh at
their foxcom Factory facilities that are
up in arms and revolting
well we want cheap stuff you know yeah I
want to work come on I wonder if you
could make it so when someone bought an
item they felt the pain and suffering of
every human that made the item and then
that will have to decide if they were
going to buy it or not doesn't it feel
that whenever there's an interesting
question about that though for some of
these people who uh this this is the way
it's often described when people are
positive towards like Sweatshop labor
they say these people live in
underdeveloped regions
are they better off
with no money per day starving or a
dollar per day working what do you think
I mean that's probably working
see I guess the issue is
it's none of our effing business it
would be better if an American worker
was getting 15 an hour to do that same
labor and they can figure out their own
issues you want to invest in the
development of that Nation by all means
go ahead and do so that sounds fantastic
sounds very nice of you to help these
people you know rise up become better
and and build better lives but why take
jobs in Industry from the United States
where American workers need these jobs
and then send them over to these
countries
because it's effectively slave labor
because they can sell the iPhone for 700
instead of 1900 what it would cost if we
built it over in the United States
probably if they built it here the
iPhone would still cost the same thing
their margins would be lower so they
build it over there ship it back here my
favorite story is how they make
skateboards they they cut down trees in
Canada send those trees to China where
they're turned into skateboards and then
sent to California to get put into
warehouses and distributed across the
U.S that's the stupidest thing I ever
heard but it's because it is cheaper to
burn all of that energy sending Lumber
to China than it is just to pay a North
American worker to do work
that's insane yeah that's you look when
they talk about climate change and all
that stuff supporting the American
worker one of the best things you can do
to prevent climate change stop over
developing other nations how about that
you're concerned about carbon then stop
building factories or in in these
countries you want you want to reduce uh
climate change stop running all the fuel
stop shipping Goods to China for
manufacturing just do it here yep stop
planned obsolescence stop these products
being made in a way that they break down
within a year or two years so you have
to buy a new one again this larger kind
of consumerism this larger quasi
corporate quasi-government policy that
has been instituted on everyone doesn't
work in anyone's favor and is
essentially a larger scam against
everyone so this is what we need to
realize everything everywhere we look
it's a scam
how else can you how else can you answer
how else can you answer that question
you mean like capitalism is a scam no uh
that thing everywhere but
them saying the way that the system the
way that the system runs the way that
the system has been uh finagled for the
personal benefit of a lot of these
billionaires that do support China that
want China to be an example for the rest
of the world that right there is rigged
apple is supporting the Chinese
government the U.S government is now
dependent on the Chinese government on
those factories on everything being
shipped to the United States including
of course our medicine our vitamins our
supplements all the plastic all the
trinkets all of that is being made in
China right now and we are dependent on
it because we got rid of our own
industry we got rid of our own
infrastructure we took the jobs we took
the factories we had them here we had
the infrastructure to make things that
would actually last would actually be
good and we said no we're just going to
send them over to China to run this
larger Ponzi scheme on everyone and the
person who did it was David Rockefeller
and Henry Kissinger with their open
China policy Kissinger still is being
adored by Donald Trump adored by Joe
Biden adored by Obama Obama's National
Security advisor said that they took
their their daily orders from Henry
Kissinger this guy's still calling the
shots here this is absolutely crazy and
bewildering that we're living in a
society where we're just being scammed
every single day how old is Kissinger
he's still around yes he's still around
he's still giving speeches I think he's
99. didn't he is he the architect of the
Vietnam War
I I don't know if you could call him the
architect but there was many human
rights violations that he committed in
Cambodia in in the south of Asia in
Chile in Latin America in the Middle
East uh I mean this guy is also the
figurehead of the petrol dollar I mean
this guy's behind almost every nook and
corner of secret society whether it's
the trilateral commission Council on
Foreign Relations or the Bilderberg
Group this guy's behind all these
organizations calling the shots
essentially telling people what to do
he's 99 by the way but but see when when
he passes is there anyone who can take
that mantle and and provide that same
advice or control there's probably a
whole bunch of other people that are
that are in secret his his underlings
Klaus Schwab was was working Kissinger
Juniors yeah yeah Clark Schwab was
working with Henry Kissinger very
closely as well they're very closely
associated Claus Schwab was a student of
Kissinger
um so so that's another human being but
there but the next person we're not
going to be hearing about the next
person is working in secret is working
in the shadows and they're implementing
policies they're probably setting the
policies right now that we don't even
know about I'm concerned they're not
American that they're like corporate
they're living they're globalists right
they don't they don't care about America
they never cared about America like they
never gave a damn about this country
they don't David Rockefeller bragged in
his own autobiography how he
specifically wanted to destroy American
sovereignty these are individuals that
openly brag I came up to David
Rockefeller I was like you said this in
your book how dare you he got mad and
then ran in his car but but at the end
of the day these people love to to brag
about how they're destroying this larger
experiment that in the first time in
almost all of recorded human history has
allowed individuals to have rights and
the ability to defend themselves that is
their Chief mortal enemy that they are
trying to get rid of at all costs they
want you uh to be fat they want you to
be sad they want you to be not be able
to defend yourself they want you to be a
slave and that's essentially the system
that they're building
yeah how else can you how else can you
say it's not being built I kind of think
they don't want you to exist at all yeah
you know it's it's like it's not that
they want you to die it's that they
don't want you to be alive I think
that's why we're going to see this big
push as well for right transhumanism and
neuralink because that's the next
natural step to this I feel like you
know the tick tock generation where
everyone is tied to their phones we have
this entire generation that is very
subservient because they're so tied to
their phone they're so distracted that
they're not paying attention to what's
actually happening in the modern day
which is why the government is so easily
able to come in and Usher in all of
these totalitarian Rule and whatnot
um the next natural progression to that
is transhumanism I know Libby Emmons was
talking about how you know you get the
chip implanted in your brain at that
point how do you know what is your your
own thought or a thought being
implemented via Ai and then at that
point are you just another like product
of Technology are you just another uh
what was the word that she used
um I can't remember off the top of my
head but essentially yeah everything's
just going to crap guys there there are
two shows that I recommend there's an
episode of Stargate sg1 where they go to
the so for you you know Stargate like
there's a portal they go through it they
find other plans and so in one they send
in this drone first and it's like a
wasteland but then all of a sudden
there's like a Flash and they're in this
beautiful looking city and what it is is
this planet like had a pollution problem
everybody dies but there's this force
field surrounding the small town
everybody's networked to this machine
and there's like 1800 people who live
here what they eventually discover is
that initially the city had Millions but
the power is running out so the force
field is shrinking and people are dying
so to maintain the system people have to
be culled so the computer was wiping
their brains of memories of people who
were being sacrificed and they didn't
know so they meet a guy then like later
in the day they watch the guy walk out
to his death and they're like what was
that and they're like who are you
talking about that and that person never
lived here we've always been a small
City then there's an episode of our
Outer Limits where it's called the
stream or something where there are
these like Wi-Fi nodes everywhere and
everybody's like got a brain chip and
they don't realize that their thoughts
are implanted they think they're
individuals they think they're living
their normal life but they're acting at
the behest of the machine or whatever
and that's the danger of the brain chip
and I just kind of wanted to ask you
Savannah really quickly and then we
could go to You're echoing what I'm
thinking but I just want to ask you
specifically what do you think the end
game is what do you think is their goal
I think the end game is to create an
entire population that is subservient to
the government that is you know tied to
AI transhumanism where we're not
fighting back we're not pushing back why
is censorship so important right now
because we are highlighting that these
issues are prevalent and that they're
happening
um but the government wants to come in
and they want everybody to be distracted
one of the things that I focus in on and
I've been thinking about this a lot
because there's a part of me that thinks
sometimes that what I do is useless
because I can sit here all day long and
scream to high heaven about what is
happening in society but it really is up
to the masses to actually act on it
right so what is the the true solution
to this and the true solution is
traditional family and instilling that
because for example the New York Post
just put out this article that talked
about these parents having to send their
kids to counseling because of all of the
drug abuse that's happening and these
kids are being exposed to it it's
horrifying them these parents are the
ones that are thinking of moving out of
the big cities crime rates and drug use
are affecting these people specifically
because they have a family and that's at
the Forefront from them that's why in
our society today we're trying to
destroy Traditional Values to destroy
traditional family because then the
average person doesn't really care about
what's going on then the average person
is just tied to their cell phone they
don't really care okay they live in the
Pod they'll watch porn all day uh you
know they're I guess living off of the
whatever app that they're they're living
through so I'm like completely
butchering this but the point that I'm
trying to make here is I feel like the
ultimate end game is to have an entire
population that's not going to push back
against a One World Government
yeah that very much scares me about
implanting memory I think you're right
really onto something with that because
memory itself is flawed no human is
Perfect Memory I think the things I
think may or may not have been what
really happened sometimes I'm just wrong
I'll say it and I'll go back and I'll
review the tape and I'll be like oh what
I remembered was different than what
happened I can only imagine that I mean
with TV and radio like that's already
manipulating our thoughts and memories
I think you're I think you might be onto
it like a muted or docile populace is
helpful for a government uh in some ways
so that the government the populace
doesn't overtake the government exactly
let's do a hard segue into this story uh
with Alex Jones we have this from
timcast.com quote burning hell Hitler
Alex Jones comments on yay interview
quote I felt like I was sucked into a
giant publicity stunt said the Infowars
host so uh everybody remembers what
happened when yay went on Alex Jones He
also went on with Gavin McGinnis and I
guess what what Alex was saying is that
before the show they agreed not to talk
about that stuff then when they're
showing on the air that's all they
talked about and he feels like it was a
big publicity stunt
I I think Alex uh his comments were
pretty interesting he said that uh yay
Kanye had a fifth grade level
understanding of Hitler he also
challenged Nick Fuentes to a debate uh
about history and specifically World War
II there was also a reference to him
potentially being a homosexual uh so so
Alex kind of kind of went off a little
bit here I don't know if he felt
pressure but we got to understand Alex
was the man that has been talking about
um the Prescott Bush he's been talking
about Margaret Sanger he's been talking
about a lot of American Elites financing
this larger Eugenics depopulation Nazi
World War II kind of movement
um this was kind of his moment to kind
of Bring It Back some people are saying
he should have brought it back when yay
was on and pushed back a little bit more
but that's up to people's own
interpretations of how they saw the
interview I don't know what did you
think of that interview and what do you
think about his latest comments now
talking about fifth grade level
understanding of World War II I think
that the interview that Alex did with
hea was really important because it
highlighted why the first amendment is
important in the sense of the reason why
I'm a free speech absolutist is because
I think that you should allow your enemy
or just anybody in society right to
really say what they think about certain
issues I think that free speech is so
effective because it essentially allows
people to expose themselves to expose
what they really think to expose and
allows the public as well to decide if
their views are good or bad so I think
you know yay going on with Alex Alex not
really pushing back was a good way for
the public to really I guess delve into
what Kanye actually thought about this
issue regarding what Alex is saying now
um I do think that Kanye is being used
by the people that are around him I'll
be honest with it Tim you disagree with
me on this look when we hear that Alex
you know Alex is saying that they agree
not to talk about this stuff about
Hitler and all that and then they did
anyway and he felt like it was a
publicity stunt that's exactly what I
was saying it felt like exactly like the
whole thing was planned out so a couple
points maybe it's being a dead horse but
you know uh yay went on with Gavin
McInnis we'll talk about that but a
couple points like they initially asked
us for a return flight right after the
show we couldn't do it it was not that
we were told by the uh we couldn't get a
flight it was impossible they ended up
getting a private plane ready to go
right afterwards they also said we'll
talk about the campaign the plans and
then immediately jumped into this stuff
same thing to do with Alex Jones so uh
the other thing too is when I look at
what happened with Gavin McGinnis yay is
just saying the craziest possible things
he's doing it again I want to give a
shout out to Viva Frey and uh Robert
Barnes because Barnes made a really
really great Point uh something that we
missed obviously and it's that yay's
talking about this tax liability that
he's got 50 million dollars or whatever
and they're trying to put him in jail
and he was saying that we didn't notice
and we should have pressed on it he's
right
maybe yay is trying to appear crazy so
he doesn't go to prison so that he can
come off as like mentally unwell he
didn't intentionally what did what did
Barnes say the example he gave was that
yay is going to come out with the
defense that the reason he didn't pay
taxes he was scared that I was going to
go to the Jewish people or something
like that like he'll he'll make up an
excuse so it sounds like he's unhinged
and then he gets a slap on the rest
minimum security thing instead of like a
serious attack 25-year tax evasion thing
so so yay goes on with gav McGinnis and
he says he what did he do he called for
Jewish people to forgive Hitler it's
just just really really out there is is
putting it lightly I mean it's nuts it's
nuts and uh in it this is amazing Gavin
McGinnis is like when you meet someone
you judge them like by the individual
right he's like I don't yay just
outright says it there's there's no way
okay like here's here's my issue I think
Barnes may be right about him trying not
to not to go to jail for tax evasion or
whatever the issue is but like it seems
like Kanye is
is is pretending to be crazy poorly you
know what I mean like Maybe not maybe
because people believe it they're like
how could he say such things like well
he's just saying stupid crazy and
outrageous like he's always been crazy
and outrageous that's why for me I feel
like it's him being used by the people
around him to push his specific message
or narrative you know whether or not he
agrees with that
I I don't know I've been a Kanye West
fan for a long time I also have not met
him in person like you guys have so I
feel like my commentary is based on what
I'm seeing in the headlines you guys
have more of a background he was totally
different yeah before the camera off
camera totally different and I kind of
wish we kind of filmed a little bit just
to give people a perspective because
everything was very cordial very you
know understanding a lot of the
craziness and nonsense wasn't there and
then the cameras went on it was like a
different person it was sitting there a
different vibe a different energy and
everything just changed in the room see
I think he's not just like empty K Ultra
by Hollywood so but this is the thing
everything we're hearing like the things
that announce Jones the thing he said on
Gavin McGinnis the things he said here
is only what people saw publicly that's
why I thought the behind the scenes
scenes things with him that we did was
so important because for whatever reason
he was you watch that video and he's
just like yeah he's very very calm very
chill he's like welcome to Luke and he's
like we got to figure out how to get
better food in this house he looks at me
he's like we should put him in charge of
getting the food that'd be really great
yeah totally different camera goes on
and he's losing he he appears to lose it
it looks like a performance he goes on
Alex Jones wearing a Balenciaga [ __ ]
mask and then he's he's got a net and
he's going you'll be meaning with them
we're gonna take your kids and it's
you're you're looking at this like is
this guy of his mind but you see him off
camera before the show and he's having
an intelligent normal conversation with
you as soon as the camera turns on come
on man AJ Alex Jones Is Right put some
money in the jar whoever's here go down
to where Alex Jones is right there put
money in he said he felt like he was in
one big publicity stunt I think he's
right yeah but at the same time in a
court of law you know being you know
allegedly anti-semitic isn't an excuse
for an insanity though what Barnes was
saying is that Kanye will come out and
say he didn't pay taxes because you know
it's going to go to all the Jewish
people who control everything that would
be his his weird crazy excuse or
something it would be interesting to
look at the what was it Wesley Snipes
I think that was the example that he
referenced it would be interesting to
look at that particular case and see
exactly what happened there just to get
a reference of how that that that
previously played out to how you know
what what might be the strategy here but
who knows at the end today what are you
think Ian well I'm glad you're more more
of an empath than intuitive person I was
thinking about this as like of the long
term like where is this along the path
of humanity when we look back in a
thousand years like what what was
happening right now and what will they
remember it happening I think what's
happening is
crazy it is is Kanye's waking up a bunch
of Jewish people and pointing them to
God like last night on that Gathering
against interview I'll explain it Gavin
was like I don't know about that one Ian
yeah Gavin's like because Nick was
saying oh there's a cabal or they were
saying there's a cabal of people that
are preventing Kanye from you know
getting to another Echelon of wealth or
whatever there's a cabal and kind of
like it's the Jewish people and uh Gavin
was like I I don't think they're Jewish
if you don't believe in God you're not
Jewish and it's something I said last
week too so Gavin if you're listening
hell yeah dude nice one and it's true
and I think no no that's that's not true
let me finish please I I understand but
I wanna I wanna like if you make a point
just explain if you make like 12 points
in a row we can't address all of them
it's called the Gish Gallop so when you
said a few things right now that I think
need to be addressed one you can be
ethnically Jewish and not religious yeah
well I think you need a different word
for that okay well that's that's that's
an important thing to make one two two
it's like saying the word means two
different things it's nonsense the word
means something what does the word mean
what does Jewish mean okay let's define
it and move on you know maybe two
definitions you can say religiously or
you can say ethnically then right well
I'm talking about I'm just talking about
the word what does the word mean let's
be specific the word means that you're
Jewish meaning what that you're a Jew
meaning what do you believe in God
that's the tenet of Judaism that's like
the tenet I'm pretty sure we have people
here who are ethnically Jewish their
parents were like if your
great-great-grandparents were Jewish
then that doesn't mean that you are you
got to believe in it it's a process it's
like an understanding
uh this is my thoughts are that what's
going to happen is people are realizing
like if you're falling if you're a
fallen Jew if you've like no longer
believed in this and you're just this
atheist taking advantage of people
you're going to realize that God is is
great that it's like it's there for all
of us we're all in this together and I
think that what's happening is there's a
there's there's going to be a revelation
within Judaism and probably all all the
major religions on Earth that there's
going to be some sort of transformation
where people come back to the faith and
Kanye will be looking at someone that
saved the Jews a Reformation yeah I just
have to say Ian because he returned him
to God I I think this may be one of the
most insane things I've ever heard sure
man I'm talking about what people it's
dude people right let me just they're
often told they're crazy when they're
talking let me just clarify a few things
Kanye West said he wouldn't he said
Jewish people aren't allowed to be in
control of things he said the only way
he would allow them to work for them if
he could put cameras in their houses and
spy on them and and you think that's him
saving them well I think Savannah's on
is something that Nick has been tweaking
his mind the last two weeks with a bunch
of anti-Semitic stuff Nick when he was
pressed when Gavin told Nick I don't
think they're Jewish I think if you
don't believe in God you're not Jewish
and Nick was like okay maybe these
people aren't Jewish maybe it's Godless
people atheists okay maybe but then
immediately Nick switched to like but
Jesus Christ is the is the King and is
the great God and it's the same stuff
Kanye's been splattering like this deep
Christian belief stuff like you got to
get out of that and become like so yeah
but I agree with you Kanye has said some
madly racist stuff in the last and or or
see that's the thing is it race it's not
even a race it's a religion it's so
confusing on purpose there's there's an
ethnicity as well it's the only religion
on Earth that happens
you look like you want to say something
this might get me canceled but my
legitimate question I guess for the
entire movement because you know what
I'm at the point where I do feel like
the term anti-Semitism has been
extremely overused I am and I want to
know your guys's viewpoint on okay can
we legitimately criticize the Jewish
Community or people who are Jewish that
are in power are we allowed to criticize
that or is that anti-Semitism because I
think what this is linking to is that
broader conversation and I think a lot
of people in the right wing do have that
question I would like your guys's
viewpoints on it because I think this is
something that a lot of people
question but we don't really talk about
I think if you just hate somebody you
know that that's hatred that's because
of how they were born or how they look
or their religion that that's wrong but
I think government should be criticized
no matter what kind of government it is
including the you know Israeli
government or or Israeli individuals so
I think that's the distinction that I
see myself Gavin again McGinnis made a
point he said when you meet someone
there are blanks let you treat them as
an individual and so the issue with the
with the yay stuff is
uh he mentioned Jon Stewart uh I
mentioned Dave Chappelle they both made
a similar point in Hollywood and media
there's a lot of Jewish people the
problem is Kanye explicitly stated in
more than one interview he lumps all of
them together regardless of of what that
really means so like I think I think the
issue is if you take a look at Harvard
Asian people are overrepresented in
Harvard does it does not mean you go up
to an Asian person and be like this
person must be good at math you know
it's it's you treat the individual like
the individual Me growing up uh in
Chicago with my friends we had some
Asian friends who are as dumb as a box
of rocks then of course you see the
tropes about certain things what we end
up what I end up learning I should say
in my view the reason Asians may be
overrepresented in Harvard is because
the culture that that they inherit its
cultural elements are studiousness and
punctuality and it's like strictness and
authoritativeness and authoritarian like
we see in the Chinese Communist party so
you look at people who come from that
culture they're going to have a very
very distinct and strict way of raising
their kids those kids are more likely to
exhibit certain behaviors like they're
going to be studious if I were to come
out and just be like wow that proves it
Asian people are all one way or another
it's just not correct so the issue is
when people say the issue is Jewish
people it's the same thing as the left
saying Asians should have a higher
standard to get in college because
they're Asian and I'm like no none of
that a person comes up to me I say who
are you what do you want what does this
mean I don't think Asians are conspiring
to get into colleges Asians are suing to
keep people out of colleges well there
are people who are Asian who are suing
Harvard but it's because Harvard's
making it hard on these individuals who
may not have I'll put it this way poor
working-class Asian people being told
they can't go to Harvard is to me
completely insane completely insane and
I'm not going to blame all Asian people
for filing lawsuits against Harvard
because Harvard is concerned that more
Asians means less Hispanics or black
people you know what I think it's all
white guys that are responsible for all
of our wrongs are of our ills everything
wrong in this Society is because of
white guys I say that as a proud person
of color and uh when whenever we do this
I I think it needs to be called out
especially when it comes to kind of
generalizations I think we should always
try to be more specific but again if you
have hatred for somebody that's that's
just because of the the way they are
that's just wrong that's just how I
plainly see it see and okay so this is
my legitimate questioning too and for
example Kyrie Irving Nike just dropped
him right because he shared a link to an
allegedly anti-semitic documentary I've
never seen the documentary myself so
maybe it is anti-Semitic I'm not sure
but when people call that out and say
okay why do we see this consistent
pattern of people sharing something the
the media immediately labeling it as
anti-Semitism this person getting
canceled this is a pattern that we have
seen a time or two why is it that we're
not allowed to speak about this again
this is just me questioning these things
but but we are speaking about it right
now uh the story about Kyrie Irving has
been talked about a whole lot and uh
it's cancel culture and we think it's
wrong like Luke has the Kyrie Irving
Jersey that he puts up periodically I
think people should be entitled to free
speech they should be allowed like in
2018 when Twitter started Banning people
alt-right individuals I did an interview
with insiders Oliver Darcy saying like
this is wrong they shouldn't be doing
this right it it it's weird to me that
you people are acting like the issue
with uh Kanye West and what he's saying
about Jewish people is unique I'm like
what are you talking about like there's
tons of instances where people have said
something offensive and then gotten
canceled over it and we've argued that
shouldn't be happening right yeah what
happened to Kyrie is absolutely insane
and I think he had a big Target on his
back especially with what happened
within the last few years with him
standing up for uh his personal freedom
to choose not to be vaccinated he was
punished by a lot of people the
corporate media attacked him and I think
they're they're just looking for any
reason just to try to get him out of the
the discourse just to try to stop him as
much as they can and he literally
tweeted uh I don't think it was even a
link I think it was a photo I think it
was a poster for a documentary they also
tried to get him in trouble for posting
clips from Alex Jones so he he's an
individual that I routinely put you know
the Jersey behind because I think he's
unfairly punished I I think a lot of the
stuff that he's going through is
absolutely ridiculous he donated a half
a million dollars to the ADL he
apologized for sharing a link without
even giving it any excuse me for sharing
a photo of a documentary without even
giving it any context and and they still
decided to let me ship him and cancel it
that's all that's over and that's crazy
and I agree with you that's something
that deserves pushback on but when
someone is hateful against someone else
they should be called out as well right
it's it's and it's not unique to Jewish
people I'll give you a few examples
Netflix executive who was this is I
think in 2018 was giving examples of of
hate speech saying the slurs so people
in the meeting went to the exec went to
HR and complained yeah they called him
and they said what did you say it's like
I was explaining these are words that
shouldn't be used on Netflix specials
what words he said they went they fired
him you had the race car driver race car
driver whose dad in the 80s used the
n-word on the radio so sponsors pulled
out from him he didn't even do anything
cancel culture is insane I I think it's
and and I get all of the the woke crazy
uh leftist organizations writing
articles about it because I said the
Alex Jones interview with yay was good
because it shows us exactly what yay
believes and immediately people were
like hey man I don't want to be
Associated I don't like that that those
are bad ideas
I don't think we should shut down
people's lives take away their bangs
destroy everything because they think
things that I think are stupid or wrong
right I think we we just speak up we
have conversations like this and explain
why we think they're right yeah I mean
look what happened to Salman Rushdie a
couple weeks ago I mean that deserves to
be discussed I think uh if we're going
to be talking about a lot of this stuff
when we're going to be talking about
this conversation again uh I think
blanketly it's just very easy to say Hey
you hate somebody because of the the way
that they're they're born you're a
jackass and I think it's that simple and
I think at the end of the day we should
be going to that and not just using this
as a way to divide and conquer people
and use it as a way to control speech
and to punish people for daring to
express ideas uh because I I think we
also reached the stage in our society
where comedy is being banned where it's
being vilified where it's being stopped
comedy used to bring people together it
used to make people laugh about our
differences we can't even have that
anymore we just have people are afraid
to even speak to each other and that to
me is is an absolutely dangerous
ingredient towards a society that is on
the verge of collapsing let me let me
give another example Dave Chappelle and
Jon Stewart both came out and made these
statements that that Kanye and I
actually mentioned Jon Stewart said
something to the effect of if you can't
if you overuse the phrase anti-semitic
when someone points out there are a lot
of Jewish people in Hollywood or in
Media or in finance then this is what is
breeding the conspiracies basically it's
what's making people feel like their
ideas may be correct and if you want to
have an honest conversation you start
with yes we we do see in certain areas
of representation that was Jon Stewart
Dave Chappelle made the joke where he
said if it's an Italian guy it's the mob
if it's a black guy it's a gang and if
it's a bunch of Jewish people it's a
coincidence how to talk about it that
was Dave Chappelle's joke Jon Stewart
and Dave Chappelle's lives have not been
destroyed they've talked about it
they've addressed it it's come up here
the thing about what Kanye said is Kanye
praised Hitler yeah he's on a different
level Kanye said they're not allowed to
control things and he would only hire
them if he can follow them home put
cameras in their house to prove they
aren't Spies Like okay if you said that
about any ethnic group people are gonna
get mad at you yeah well I mean I think
Kanye has just been an interesting
example of bringing this conversation to
the Forefront and again too it really
was a test of freedom of speech right
and who in our in the right wing I guess
area really is truly pro-free speech
because granted I don't agree with a lot
most of what Kanye said probably all of
what Kanye said it was pretty crazy but
again still support his right to say it
same thing with Nick Fuentes I still
support their right to say and I think
that's the beauty of the Free Speech
Free Speech right is you allow your
opponent to say exactly what they think
or just anybody in society exactly what
they think and then Society is allowed
to dictate if they like it or not well
you let the best idea win and you have
to counter bad ideas with good ideas
that's why I think we were trying to
facilitate a conversation here to try to
find out what the best idea was and
sadly we didn't have that but it would
have been you know contentious it would
have been interesting but I think it's
worthwhile to challenge bad ideas and I
think we need to do this more routinely
than than a lot of other people do it
when you we we got a Super Chat that I
want to address before we go to super
chats because someone just mentioned is
an interesting point they said you're
still not listening to Sav she's asking
why you can say collusion between white
people white person abuses people but
it's not okay to say Jewish person
so let me explain from where I come from
my point is I have routinely ragged on
the left for blaming white people it
will not be any different when someone
wants to blame Jewish people I do not
like people looking at someone and being
like you know what I've made a decision
about you just because you look a
certain way that's nonsense to me I just
don't I don't think it's legitimate I've
met I remember I knew this Haitian guy
when I worked at O'Hare and he was
complaining how people call him
African-American but he's from Haiti
he's like he's not from Africa he's not
American either he's Haitian don't call
me that it's like this stupid like
judging a person for this I agree the
left when they blame white people for
everything is ridiculous and it's wrong
I also think it's wrong on people like
Kanye or anyone else blame Jewish people
for it I also think it's wrong to blame
black people for it I'm like let's blame
criminals let's blame thieves let's
let's blame corruption and let's try to
figure out how uh we live and work
together and we don't blame each other
just because we look a certain way
because I I just man I'm imagining just
just the idea of just racism in general
it really does make me angry same yeah
like judging someone in any capacity
without actually knowing who they are
and knowing what they believe is a
problem because then what you're going
to be a person who likes white people
okay guess what all the antifa people
overwhelmingly white so it's certainly
not white people that are good or better
no because Auntie was out of their out
of their minds then you've got Latinos
you've got people from Cuba who love
America more than these white antifa
yeah I just you know that's just me
that's just me I'm saying you know
they're self-hating white people just
like there's Jewish people you became
systems that breed these kinds of
problems like the Roman Empire is the
white the white person problem is the
Roman patriarchy that thing created a
church to get into people's minds it
tried to control the world it's still
trying to control the world through its
Church like that's the white person
problem is the Roman patriarchy that's a
real thing the Jewish problem is the
banking cartels that were invented by am
shell Rothschild in the 1500s his three
sons went off to England Italy and Fran
chance to make the Rothschild banking
Empire it's the banking superstructure
that's the problem not the race or the
culture doesn't matter what you look
like it's the behavior and I think I
think Jones actually made that point and
then yay admitted he was wrong he said
he shouldn't have blanketed all people
and that it's actually about Banking and
stuff like that see and that's the thing
Kanye that's inconsistent
feel like when he does get that back
he's like okay
you know we looked up the CEOs of banks
because we're talking with Michael
malice and it's like the CEOs a bunch of
these banks are just white dudes yeah
it's so it's I don't know man I I this
is the problem I have mainly it's
because I want to solve these problems
why is the Federal Reserve ripping
people off and destroying everything
well if you come out and just scream
that someone's like religious background
or ethnic background I'm like bro that
bro that's not the problem is the system
and it's being supported by a whole
bunch of people of all different
backgrounds yeah how are you going to
solve anything by saying you know
specifically you know focusing on some
of the outer details rather than the
actual core issues of the problem and
the effects of it it's like this it's
like a homeless white man has privilege
and Oprah Winfrey is disadvantaged yeah
sorry dude I'm not buying that when they
come out and they say white people this
is white heteronormative patriarchy I'm
like shut up dude in New York City they
implemented uh resources in the official
School Board there that made sure this
is this is at the the head of the
Department of Education in New York City
that if you're a white student that's
poor resource shouldn't be going to you
they should be going to a rich black
person a black kid mainly because of the
institutionalized racism inside of that
that school or structure that's the
policies that are being implemented
right now that are absolutely insane
that need to be pushed back on and are
racist you know for the record when it
comes up against Semite is uh more than
just an error or more than just a Jew
it's an Arab it's Phoenician Acadian
it's all those people from that
Southwestern Asian Peninsula or area not
really Peninsula those are all semites
so if you hated Muslims during 2005 you
were an anti-semite buddy if you had if
you have anti-muslim in you you're
anti-semite I don't like that that they
they act like it's only Jewish it's like
there's a lot of people the Semitic
people were a lot of different people
right it's just another word for racism
essentially that's what the ethnic and
religious thing I think may have been
getting confused for you there but it
should be very clear when you use that
word what it means it does not mean
Jewish person there's there's tough
challenges in the space you know ever I
I think everybody gets it I grew up on
the south side of Chicago
47th Street was just north of us when
you crossed it the entire Community was
black there was an area they called the
LeClaire courts when people from when
black people from north of 47th would
come down south of 47th and then there
was this thing where a bunch of young
girls would Rob young girls south of
47th and it was always a racial
disparity you'd see a lot of that the
cops wouldn't let you go north of 47th
and I'm like
look man I'm not stupid enough to think
that this is the problem of someone's
race it's a problem of two distinct
communities that don't see each other
and it may be a component of race that's
why they don't view each other as like
part of the same Community but a lot of
it was constructed a lot of the project
housing the redlining the blockbusting
created this element so when you go into
areas where it's like mixed everybody's
getting along right so I think what
happens is a lot of people see something
like that they see these barrier streets
in New York I lived in Crown Heights and
there was a split between the Jewish
neighbor and the black neighborhood and
they had shootouts because they were
rival drug dealers right A lot of people
thought it was like a race war or an
ethnic thing and then you and then I
learned from the people actually
involved they were like nah it's just
because they're trying to sell drugs
over here and so why is it that they
were it was tended to be black people
fighting against Jewish people was not
the race it was that if you lived in
this area the dealers you were working
with it was a Jewish neighborhood if you
lived in this area the deals you're
working with it was in a black
neighborhood this is like a deep problem
in in cities with racial segregation and
there's a lot of uh components to it
that I think are real notably that
people choose to live in areas where
people look like each other that is what
you know creates racism or as a
component of it me personally I'm gonna
try to avoid stereotyping someone based
on experiences like that and let someone
be an individual so they can uh be as
worthy as they chew used to be yeah man
there's groups and cabals and gangs are
real they're real people can get
together and sometimes you know you you
get with what you know a lot of times
that's the easiest thing path of least
resistance if you speak the same
language if I don't know if they look
like you maybe it's easier to to
identify but Jessica's groups are real
doesn't mean that people aren't
individuals when you see their eyeballs
you realize the skin suit is almost
irrelevant the brain stem creature is
like what we really are floating in
these meat sacks pulling on electrodes
getting our bodies to move around but
you see the humanity in their eyes man
you get right through that right through
that I thought racism was gone in 2008
for for there was a brief moment of a
year where everyone was the same and I
used that word hyperbolically because I
know we have genetic differences but
we're so similar
so freaking similar in group out group
situation yeah I'll tell you this we
look at that that poll that data that
shows that white Liberals are the only
group with an outgroup preference that
shows that among black people Asian
people let Latino they have an in-group
racial preference they are slightly more
inclined to want to be around people who
are of the same ethnic background or
Race White conservatives same thing it's
slight it's not definitive liberals the
only with a negative they don't like
being around white people that's
interesting yeah so I think Tucker
Carlson had the nail on that with a
hammer when he said he was like I'm not
racist it's white liberal women they're
the ones who are voting for all these
policies and doing all these things I
was a white liberal I'm like is that
racist and sexist though because you're
calling out white white women I didn't
like being around only people I was born
in Cuyahoga Falls they call it Caucasian
Falls because it's like 99.9 white
people and I was disgusting like until I
was 18 it was like racist and I left
went to New York City Chicago La I just
wanted to be around different cultures
that was the white liberal in me I
couldn't stand just being isolated in
this one monocle why was it disgusting
because I knew there was more I knew
that racism wasn't right it didn't sound
right I knew that how was it racist if
there was like overwhelmingly white they
would make racist jokes about other
people other races and stuff and it was
just like okay if you if you if you were
like no that's not good then you could
ostracized by the group of racists and
so my I'm forced like it's a little guy
I want to say they're all racist but I
think they're just inherent racism in
all of us from that environment where
it's like that was normal and our
parents had come from racist
environments
um I had to get out of it I had to see
the world
um then I went to South America man
that's like the other end of the
spectrum where I was the odd man out and
that was that was a very lonely
experience too anyway I advise everyone
get a chance to dip into another culture
I live down a normal Avenue in L.A and
it's Doom
what does that mean it's like the the
Latina man they're getting Wild on
Sunday you know they got the food carts
going and dancing and playing music at
church we used to have the elotes carts
in this on the South Side by Venom Park
race to hang out and then the mayor
banned them yeah they were only allowed
on the other side of Cicero where all
the Billboards turned Spanish that was
deeply offensive to me because it was
like it was the most fun thing when the
Lotus cart pulled up you had a dollar
and he shaved the corn into the cup with
some mayo some Parmesan some red some
cayenne pepper Stir It Up hand it to you
yeah a cup of corn and then and then we
don't know why but he would but there
was like a rule put in place Banning
them from from the west side of Cicero
Avenue yeah and that just happens to be
like a dividing line where you start
seeing more more Hispanic and Spanish
billboards and we were like yo what the
man we love the elotes guy he was cool
and somalis he had tamales too it was so
great to just witness the humanity and
people of other of the was not race it's
not the word race isn't the right word
what's the word what's the difference
between like someone from Africa and
someone from Ireland I guess just
different cultures different cultures
but if we're both born in the United
States and we grew up across the street
from each other then what's the
difference what would you you're both
America I would still say it's more of a
culture thing though right yeah but you
said you felt isolated in South America
that was interesting because I had the
lightest skin long hair they would call
me Thor from the movie because they were
like and
um when I walk on the street I just
people would be staring at me and
looking at me and it was like I didn't
speak their language very well it was a
very weird experience I have a lot of
more empathy towards people that might
identify in an out group now yo I went
to uh Thailand during uh Chinese New
Year where'd you go uh Bangkok oh cool
and I can't remember exactly where we
were but it was this like big big Market
Avenue that went really far and it was
just crowded shoulder to shoulder with
people I could see over everyone's head
it was just um you know and like the
person I was with we were both like on
average taller than everyone and I was
like I was like wow like we're in this
country everyone here is Thai I'm like a
foot taller than everybody I'm like or
like you know half a foot taller than
everybody then I went to Sweden and I
was just like looking up at everybody
like this is very interesting yeah you
know everybody was taller than a good
conversation to have is the conversation
about genetics and the difference of
genetics they call it race realism
sometimes like but I think that's an
important Free Speech conversation to
objectively identify differentials in
genetics but also acknowledge the
similarity in our Consciousness and our
brains and our spines and stuff like
that
um but you got to be able to like with
love acknowledge the differences
what is that uh just like the big it's a
famous Market in Bangkok I'd like to
check out the name I don't know I went
to this mall that was insanely huge
though in Bangkok where they were like
it was one of the biggest malls in the
world or something like that yeah I
don't know also before we're gonna go to
super chats but I want to give a shout
out to Roberto Jr uh our rooster because
there's just something hilarious about
when you so you know they're like a foot
and a half tall but when you walk in
there Roberto Jr turns his head up to
look you in the eyes and I just think
it's funny because I'm like he doesn't
need to see my face like what you know I
don't know it's just funny like he can
see you and see what you're doing but he
wants to look up at your face and he
turns his head sideways to look at you
it's just a funny thing interesting he's
like what are you doing he's like okay
he's got to see your face right in India
I think they say dolphins and elephants
are people they give them personhood oh
wow non-human people all right if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends and become a member over at
timcast.com we're gonna have that
members only show coming up for you uh
about 11 p.m but we're gonna rate your
super chats now
all right J Mary says thanks for having
Savon y'all are the future of Journalism
because you all have integrity please
stay safe out there and remember
Pioneers take the arrows we all have our
part to do wow wow
enlightened fool says Crowder's
interview with Alex Jones was
enlightening very interesting indeed do
for you says home invasion cast yeah
yeah another person showed up to the
same property and uh people were saying
it's not they claim to be a fan and
they're like it's not a fan it's Recon
and I'm like yeah no I I get it and I
think I'm you know clearly it's not a
fan because nobody would show up to this
property a day after a bullet was just
shot at two other Home Invaders so it's
like may be trying to come back to case
The Joint maybe because they drop stuff
and they need an excuse to go check it
out look testing security seeing the
response seeing who's there seeing if
you know what's the response time who's
going to show up you know there's a lot
of
crazy-ish going around there to any of
the other fans in the chat don't do that
don't do it yeah I don't think anybody
showing up the properties are a fan of
anything no I think it's just an excuse
but the excuse doesn't work like none of
our security guys are assuming anybody
showing up as a fan
they're like doesn't matter if what you
think you are like death threats are
death threats yeah coming coming
Uninvited is not nice Red Hood 13 says I
want to see a new Burn Notice series
quote I used to be a spy until I quit
and started to work at Twitter
haha
Midas says the country and the
government is now a facade for the elite
the government takes and abuses power
and then no one does anything because
people expect the government the police
government to police itself we need to
start policing the government
politicians should fear us
ostracizing them and shunning them I'd
put it this way don't let politicians
into your business
you know hey if they want to make
political uh affiliation or protected
class outside of DC then maybe but uh
there's a only a handful of politicians
I'd be willing to like make a burger for
you know I like what you said yesterday
about uh you know the police that are
coming in and shutting down American
business owners don't allow them in any
other business right you know make their
make their faces known make their names
known I like they think that's a really
good of way of you know pushing back
non-violently but it would require the
people of Fredericksburg to all
recognize who these people are these
cops and then agree politically so
what's going to end up happening is
you're going to get leftists who for no
other reason than the cops are being
shunned by anti-vaxxers we'll start
serving them despite the fact that the
defund the police faction so it's very
strange right because I feel like antifa
is almost there with their with their
mindset they're almost there but they're
not quite there yet Stephen zillajin
says wish Pelosi gave Tim an excuse to
break out his impression he sounds like
Will Ferrell doing Harry Carey in a
female tone yeah
Donald Trump is just so awful
[Laughter]
I mean but it's a contentionally gross
you know yeah of course of course
you know and just try to
because that's that's how I feel when
she talks that's how I feel yeah yeah
Ram Roy says this gas station thing
feels like something out of the stalker
series what's that do you guys know what
that is uh it's like a video game I
believe s dot T dot stalker I don't
remember exactly it's like it's in
Russia a russian-based game
so apparently everybody seems to know
what that Bullpup shotgun is and they're
coming up with different ideas uh one
person said it looks like a Tavor 12
nine millimeter or the other is a Tavor
95 and nine millimeter uh let's see
Ashton says it's an MDR Bullpup by
Desert Tech then we have uh what does it
say the mercenary says that weapon in
the video looks like a shotgun with a
chamber looking like the it fits the
size of a 12 gauge shotgun shell my
deadhead one like that it looks just
like a bull pump 12 gauge that I have as
well then uh Josh V says Bullpup shotgun
look at the mag well and bolt size there
you go a lot of people responding yep a
lot of people saying uh Chris Vang says
12 gauge Bullpup look at the magazine
the magazine is very blocky there you go
let's see two stalorum says private
security carry beanbag rounds and
shotguns Ergo it's not a Bullpup it's an
assault beanie
how nice
all right we'll do for use is the
firearm you're trying to figure out is
an ATI Bulldog or a Tokarev TB V12 I
don't know it may be those things I know
that I have a Bullpup 12 gauge that is
not one of those I don't know I don't
it's is it you know I don't know what'd
the other person say the desert one
sounded like it might be it
yeah
there you go
okay faloke says we are a civilization
in Decline we think we are just more
aware of the conspiracies the truth is
wicked people can't even conspire
competently anymore compare even the
honeyed words of snakes then and now
there is no comparison
yeah I think that Martin Luther King's
statement where it's uh the the true
what is a testament of evil is not to do
evil but to sit by Will evil men do evil
and do nothing and watch it happen the
only thing required for evil to Triumph
is that good men do nothing much more
concise there's a couple different ones
like that at least we're doing something
I did nothing from 2010 to 2019 so I
feel better now yeah Todd B says Tim do
you see Crowder's interview with Jones
today tell me Jones's description of yay
doesn't sound familiar literally said
yay wouldn't talk about that stuff then
show starts and he goes into it yeah
exactly yep publicity stunt yeah so I
don't know what kind of publicity he's
looking for but he got it AJ what you
doing come on the show bro get out of
here
we'll get AJ out here uh we got to hand
him that jar yes we got to make a skit
of him being like a anti-santa Claus
coming in to steal the jar
um that was the idea that uh we already
yeah Jones has got to pay off his bills
so he goes around collecting all the
Alex Jones's right jars for everybody
and then he's able to pay it off that's
a great Vlog I think I think Sheamus did
that for Freedom Tunes oh yeah it's I
don't think so well we can do the live
action yeah we'll do live action Sheamus
did a really really good bit about the
yay thing where it's like I'm outside
and I meet yay and and I'm like oh hey
I'm Tim and he goes who is they though
I'm like that's that's Jim who was they
though that's Stephen Crowder who is
they though that's officer Bill who is
they though Kanye you got to stop
talking about people like they're not
here and then he says I think everyone
is special and have something to offer
and then I go exactly and then he says
especially Hitler and then everyone does
it you got to watch the freedom Tunes
it's funnier he just Sheamus nailed it
it's very very good
all right Kevin quas Nazar says Elon
Musk censored free speech and lied about
it changed my mind
I lied about it perhaps
um the symbol posted by Kanye is the
symbol of realism I guess it looks like
a star of David with a swastika in the
middle and it's a it's a religious group
that believes aliens created Humanity or
something like that right Elon Musk
deleted it suspended yay and said it was
for inciting violence I agree with that
no one dies no I mean I agree that he
did that I don't agree with the
Assumption no no I'm saying like no
basically everyone came out and they're
like what inciting violence he posted an
offensive image yeah like we don't have
to like the image but he didn't tell
anybody to do anything I think the first
red flag for me was when Elon based off
of his own personal feeling said that
Alex Jones couldn't come back on the
platform that was a bit big red flag for
me because again you know Elon has done
a good job of changing Twitter from its
original Origins we're in a lot better
place than we were two four years ago
however there's still work to be done
and now we just have a new person that's
allowed to be the Arbiter of what
freedom of speech really means yep
ready to rumble says please stop talking
crap about neural link because it's
going to save lives literally by helping
the paralyzed walk in the blind sea and
so much more
I agree but there's part of me that
worries that there's going to be people
who are have have injuries have a
nervous system injuries and they're
going to say yes please and I got to be
honest if it were me I'd probably say
the same thing I'd say yes give me the
implant help me walk once again but then
who knows what that implant will do to
them and I think the common sense take
on this too is do you really expect our
government not to take advantage of this
type of Technology yeah think about that
I expect them to hack into it exactly
being thought I was reading a Forbes
article earlier today about how
um you can now hack into up to 10 000
different types of vehicles and extract
people's personal data yeah As the adage
goes the path to hell is paved with good
inventions so good inventions good
inventions good intentions
Graham Godfrey says just yesterday I was
offered assisted death when canceling my
transplant we were joking about that
before the show jeez I'm kind of joking
we're talking about it that's crazy man
Canada is like just offering to kill
people yeah man I mean we're supposed to
at least the government's honest now
they're doing it secretly now they're
doing it overtly so give us props for
that we like to talk about how Simpsons
predicts a lot of things but in this
instance Futurama called it the suicide
booths my one of the best jokes is how
Bender has the coin on the string to get
his money back but he's about to kill
himself so it's just like what was the
point of doing that you know and then I
think this is the first episode saw fry
meets bender and then he pushes him back
and survives and then bender gets mad
he's like I want to rip off it's the
pilot it's like yeah the pilot see where
neuralink ends up for me is people
uploading their Consciousness to some
type of I don't know like AI cloud or
whatever and then also being a part of
the assisted suicide within their
Consciousness is in the cloud I don't
know I feel like that's where that
progression goes to there's there's a
show like that what is it what was it
called I watched it I can't remember
it's about in the future people can
upload their Consciousness when they die
so like you can retire indefinitely and
there's this dude who gets it was like a
car accident or something so they're
like well you're gonna die we can
transfer your Consciousness before you
do otherwise you're dead and then he
does is it called upload upload is that
what it is yeah maybe yeah I think so
that's a pretty good show it's an
interesting concept but uh
people will eventually just live forever
not really though like it's not really
going to be you you know you I I I I
think
we certainly don't know how to transfer
a soul or or whatever a soul like is
made of or whatever it is I don't even
know if it exists in this plane like if
you talk about DMT stuff we've had those
conversations with Michael malice and
it's it's like something connecting
people to Beyond the Veil so our soul
may not even be here so transferring it
into a machine may not even be possible
yeah unless you like
figure out a way to make an organic
brain regenerate perfectly forever and
then you'll you hook up electrodes into
a machine or something or if you could
figure out what subatomic spin is
causing the electrodes to fire the way
they're firing and you could replicate
that spin in a machine or in a subsystem
of some sort or virtually replicate the
spin you might be able to replicate the
thought patterns sure but what I mean is
that's not that's not that's not you you
know like imagine you're playing Super
Mario Brothers can you transfer Mario
into another character and it's like
well it's just you you're controlling
the player character if you leave
there's nothing there and there's no way
in the game to preserve your controls
Beyond you leaving you know what I mean
so what I'm saying is like what insoles
us here may not even be a part of this
reality in any tangible way it's it's
beyond it so it might it might it may be
Beyond any kind of reality-based physics
yeah you can replicate human thought
pattern to machine but you ain't there
yeah true what if you could keep doing
it after you die like you still have
control of your your thought patterns
because it's preserved in a machine and
you can keep talking to people after
your body's dead so like your soul
somewhere else is controlling the
machine maybe I don't know man I'm not
going to pretend to have all the answers
that's that's certainly something
a lot of people just uh you know we talk
to a lot of religious people and they
think it's not possible for the soul to
to exist in that way and no idea I would
not presume to know
all right Trace Ventura says as a huge
fan it's really upsetting that a few bad
actors had to destroy a lot of what you
guys had planned for the business many
of us may never get to meet you guys
unfortunately it's true yeah
um I don't know if you guys saw my 4 pm
video but uh creepy phone calls being
sent like veiled threats basically and
uh we get a lot more than people realize
there's a whole bunch of well I'll put
it this way behind the scenes of the
show there's a war going on and I'm not
even kidding there's a whole bunch of
stuff there's legal battles there's
death threats stuff we don't talk about
the stuff you see is surface level
swattings creepy phone calls and uh
someone tweeted at me a great Point
saying that the right has been uh
convinced has been pressured into being
silent abuse victims they need to start
talking about what's going on more and
I'm like 100 I've never I I keep hearing
it over and over again don't tell
anybody it's happening don't tell you'll
make it worse and I'm like okay just at
this point tell me how it's making it
worse because it's not stopped it's only
gotten worse will it be worse than this
okay fine whatever maybe that'll get law
enforcement if they're still in
existence to do something about it maybe
the issue is it's a low tier blunt
terrorism that never reaches the level
where any law enforcement agency
actually wants to take care of it how
about we just say it's happening and if
they want to make it worse well then
that's going to be on law enforcement to
figure it out not me well I think that
we've seen time and time again that
until you hold them accountable law
enforcement enforcement really isn't
going to do anything so yeah I say keep
you know talking about what's happening
yeah it's like a weird cold terrorism
almost they just don't say anything
about it I feel for people that are like
alone like YouTubers that are super
famous but not that wealthy and working
alone in their house and it happens to
them because like the nature of the
entertainment industry is you're going
to get weird phone calls and doxing and
crap
um but it's private security and secure
locations you need that if you're going
to be a famous entertainer there's no
such thing as a secure location anymore
just like a walled compound that yes but
like the idea that you can mask where
you are it's it's literally impossible
I've had people emailing me being like
Tim here's the trick and it's like if
you if you think we have not implemented
these these techniques and everything
it's just like look we have guests
guests have to know where we are guests
have staff they also know where we are
they tell a friend who tells a friend
who tells a friend who tells a friend
and it's impossible to keep addresses a
secret so what you really just need is a
bunch of armed dudes and a warning to
people that if you trespass you will be
presumed to be a lethal threat well in
border security show America how it's
done Tim 30-foot big concrete walls all
the way around or no we'll do Bollard
fencing around the property or just
really good self-defense training you
know what we'll do I'll just get 15
German Shepherds
that's it and then we just let him run
around yeah that'd be a lot of poop
Atlas is going to have uh you know a
litter a litter oh hell yeah so we'll
just you know raise them on the land
like Savages you know and we'll we'll
teach them a coded language that Only We
Know
that's that's the thing too um I don't
know if this is true but I heard that
with like attacked like trained dogs you
don't use uh English yeah you use
different languages and you use your own
kind of uh you make up words
so you you if you're in a conversation
with somebody you don't accidentally use
the word because dogs like German
Shepherds I have one they're they're
super smart they hear every word their
ears are always perked up and if you
could say you know I'm on guard today
and guard is the word that they're that
they're activated on you're gonna have a
problem and situation on your hand
because when they go crazy but also bad
guys can use the commands on your dog
and your trained dogs probably won't
listen but there could be circumstances
where they've got food and you know they
they try and feed the dog or something
would you guys connect 60 uh German
Shepherds to a neural network and then
put one in your brain and control them
with your brand
you probably could actually they did
that thing with the roach where they
remote controlled it what they do is
they they they create a remote control
thing for a human where they put some
device on the person that screwed with
their equilibrium and then when they
would turn the control stick it would
make the person feel like they were
going to fall over so they would try and
walk to the left to stop from falling
over and it made them like and they were
freaked out yeah that's crazy a couple
days ago when I was training my dog for
production work uh the trainer that I
worked with brought out his dog and then
I put the sleeve on and he was like let
me show you uh what the dog's capable of
doing and it is terrifying they will rip
your arm off without even thinking about
it their strength and the power and the
veracity that these dogs have within
them I mean
it's insane it's crazy Ian's eyes are
opening up so yeah you better watch out
you better treat Atlas nice Ian amazing
creature not wait wake me up in the
morning
um staff here they're listening they're
like wolves I mean that's the closest
thing to a wolf a German Shepherd is
that the closest thing to a modern wolf
in the dog well there's also Huskies
that are also very close yeah Belgian
Malinois are also being used a lot by
militaries and police but I love dogs I
grew up around dogs a German Shepherd
saved my saved my grandma's life during
World War II what happened it's an
insane story maybe we could get into it
in the after show after show yeah all
right we'll do that one
all right Tech yard says the interview
on Alex Jones was a setup I dm'd Luke we
are change with the clip
um where did you send it because I
that's my Twitter handle and Instagram
handle also there's a lot of fakes out
there so if you're seeing underscore
Luke we are change or just any other
version of it that is not actually Luke
we are change uh please report those
fake accounts uh there's a lot of people
spamming I will never be asking you for
for money uh directly through DMs so
please ignore all those fakes and I'll
check my DMs on Instagram and Twitter to
see and also Facebook that's that's me
on there too so uh yeah thanks for
sending me the clip semper Ive says Tim
you got a lot of flax saying the black
vote when saying you don't believe in
identarianism could you go into how you
are going to explain that to yay yeah
yeah uh before the show I didn't
literally say hey yay you're black
therefore black people will vote for you
I said if you're if you go door-to-door
and you ask someone Trump Biden yay
they're gonna say yay because you're
more personable you're a celebrity
people know your name I in in the
context of that I said that the cultural
stuff that he built is hip hop and stuff
is prominent in the black community he
probably would do well in in certain
areas of that he said yeah but and it
was it was funny because before the show
it was a very calm and reasonable thing
he's like yeah but you know there's a
lot of people don't like me and I'm like
no no I know of course but I think that
uh race plays a role for a lot of people
I have a story I've told about how uh
when I was skating on the south side of
Chicago my friend whose grandmother was
black said vote for Obama because he'd
be the first black president race does
play a role for a lot of people it is
not the same thing to say there's a
Jewish vote in Florida there's a Jewish
vote in New York there's a black vote in
New York there's a Latino vote in
Florida there's a Latino vote in Texas
nobody cares about that they talk about
the Jewish vote in New York all the time
no one wants to destroy your life
because you brought it up it's a false
uh it's a false equivalence like so then
what happens is yay tries to Spring like
a gotcha he goes you said I get a bunch
of black votes because I'm Black and I'm
like that's not exactly what I said it's
kind of twisting what I said I think
it's more so that when you have someone
who is successful and people can see him
as like a representation of where they
come from Chicago hip hop Urban and many
people in the black community yeah
they're going to see themselves in you
you're going to inspire them race does
play a role in that we've talked about
it a lot on this show it's it's it's
like people are trying to find a way let
me say I'll tell you guys a story man I
had a Discord server once I got rid of
it I'll tell you why
because there are people who are just
psychotically obsessed with Jewish
people the same way woke people are
psychotically psychotically obsessed
with white people and it's really
annoying to me because it doesn't
actually talk about anything it doesn't
solve any problems and so what happened
was I created I created Discord so that
we can literally we just talk about the
news like what's the news today and
there were a group of people like a
small handful that no matter what the
news was they would turn it into talk
about Jewish people and I'm like what
are you talking about we were talking
about pineapple on pizza and then all of
a sudden some guy is like I had pizza in
Israel once and I was like oh you're
kidding me dude and then someone says
you know Israel this and I'm like I'm
shutting this thing down because these
people were derailing everything and
that was probably their intent and I
said I am not going to sit here where
these people just keep spamming the same
thing over and over again there's no
conversation and it's totally pointless
that's what it felt like when I was
administrating Minds for like four years
I'm like how do I this is non-stop these
are all the people that got banned off
YouTube and Facebook for saying all this
you know stuff anti-jew I don't know if
it's anti-jew but like sympathizing with
the Nazi kind of mentality is that the
way to look at it like the Hitler wasn't
so bad-minded that wasn't that wasn't
the issue for the Discord server the
issue annoying when that comes in waves
and it's just like dude how do you stop
that but but that's not the issue the
issue was like if Israel was in the news
like was it protective Edge or whatever
some like you know Israel bombing
Palestine I have no problem people say
whatever they wanted about Israel or
Jewish people I'm like the problem was
we'd be talking about Donald Trump
wanting to like lower taxes and then
someone would turn it into a
conversation about Jewish people and I'm
like you have a psychological problem I
get it you are obsessed with this I'm
I'm folk I'm trying to do a like this
this wasn't a free speech platform this
was literally today's news subjects
discuss and then people want to shut
down the conversation and I'm like okay
we clearly can't do it this way so I'm
not interested this is great because I
think it takes a lot of heat off Jewish
people in general and refocuses on
British imperialism like the foundation
of Israel with the Mandate for Palestine
the British mandate for Palestine sign
you refocus it on Empire and take it off
of the individuals or the race or the
religions and stuff is such a better
conversation
I think it's also particularly annoying
like I did a segment today talking about
the film Wednesday the show Wednesday
Tim Burton's being accused of being
racist because two of the character two
of the characters uh the two black
characters are bullies and I'm just like
you you literally just can't have a
diverse cast right because there's no
position you can put any you know
marginalized voicing without someone
being upset about it you know we rag on
that stuff all the time when I tell
someone to shut up about white people
it's like white people aren't the
problem which is like a large bulk of
the culture War conversations it's weird
to me that people act like when we say
the same thing about Jewish people it's
Unique like why are you saying that Tim
was like we said the same thing about
when people are like oh black people
can't be bullies sure they can they can
be bullies they can be good people they
can be bad people they can be gay people
they can be Bankers they can be anything
who knows yeah but uh the funny thing
about the the Tim Burton stuff is that
the characters that are accused of being
bullies aren't even bullies they're like
actually just good guy characters like
right they're normal characters with
flaws and normal things and these people
got mad that black characters are
depicted negatively so they they got
outraged about it and then they want to
get stuff banned well and I think that's
the greater issue of our society right
is that we have the population creating
these fake problems because they've been
so coddled we have it so easy in this
country that we have to create these
fake problems and racial division is one
of the easiest things for everybody to
fight about and I truly think that's
what it is at the core of it right you
have a huge subset of the population
that truly just wants to fight for
something that wants to be the hero that
wants to have something that they're
doing positively with their lives that
they're contributing to society and
racism right now just happens to be the
easiest thing so they're making issue
out of nothing Jesse Kelly was saying
that's how communism Finds Its way into
systems is through the vulnerabilities
of the disenfranchised whoever is
feeling like a victim right now that's
perfect incubation for communist
mentality the group the government will
save us from it anti-Semitism anti-white
you know all this crap let's read this
one from Brent Brett Noel said as chat
GPT is so good already how long until it
could copy an individual speech writing
style so well that people especially
political leaders can live forever
through their AI Consciousness we're
already there apparently Facebook has
this thing or they've been working on it
where after someone dies you can take
all of their posts in chat history and
turn it into an AI I'll also mention
this homework no longer exists it
doesn't with chat AI someone tweeted
this they said write a short essay about
the uh the effect of Westward Expansion
on the Civil War and then it wrote a
page about literally that a unique
essay that you could then read through
make sure and it's all correct and then
turn it as your own well you know that's
good because I was actually just reading
an article about how a high school in
Baltimore 77 of their students were
reading at an elementary grade level so
it's a good thing that we have ai to
come and think for us because the
majority are complete and other idiots
thank you to our education system well
homework was a scam anyway yeah yeah I
thought it was dumb the entire education
system is a scam at this point it is so
it always has been the thing about these
AIS is chat GPT is an establishment
liberal someone uh had it they had it
performed the political typology quiz
and it was an establishment liberal
which is to the left of like average
Democrat and one degree to the right of
progressive leftist and it's because the
AI is trained over a decade on an
Internet that has censored all these
right-wing ideas yeah literally so
there's another video on a by
asianometry who did a video about this
and about like uh I think it's like van
Neumann uh structure and you know more
about it Ian than I would
um but he talks specifically about this
and specifically about the the chap gbt
whatever it's called
um that I watched last night that was
really interesting
um by the way if anyone's interested in
looking at it we just need to delete AI
delete the humanoid robots delete the
San Francisco robots that just got uh
you know armed or I'm sorry they're not
going to shoot you they're just going to
violently explode next to you my
apologies here
um yeah the sentient AI That's now you
know speaking to us and creating art I
don't like it I really don't how is
education gonna work are kids just gonna
download the the essay yeah the approved
narrative that's how it's gonna work
they're gonna you know insert the brain
ship download the approved narrative
beautiful think for yourself is becoming
more important yeah
that's the goal of schools maybe get us
to the point where they have to have
neuralink yeah it's like well you can't
do math anymore when was the last time
anybody actually wrote out some division
I'm in media I don't use math for a
reason you know when you go to a
restaurant the the amount of the tip is
written out for you yeah and it's like
it's funny because it's you know do
people know how to do 20 it's just like
it's like the easiest calculator ten
percent times two yeah anytime you got
to do a 30 times 30 times 40 times 50
it's just times 10 times three there's a
bunch of different ways you can do it
but nobody does anymore they look at the
receipt and the receipt says the number
and this guy sued because he found out
one restaurant was saying like 10 of
putting a higher number because nobody
knows the math
and now everyone's got many super
computers in their pockets there's a
math Forum we've outsourced the poor guy
didn't have a fact Checker to make sure
the receipt was correct you know yeah
let's see there was one Super Chat that
I wanted to read let me see if I can
find it some people mentioning that
there's definitely a Bullpup shotgun
thank you for uh
uh pointing that out and uh there's one
last one where is oh here we go
cleft the misfit says Ian Jews are not
the only group who share an ethnicity
and a religion it's very common in the
Middle East such as the druze the
yazidis as well as the rohingya and
South Asia yeah Ian yeah Ian okay thank
you there you go yeah you're right about
that for sure all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member over at timcast.com one
of the members only show coming up for
you we post them just about 11 p.m it's
going to be a lot of fun not so family
friendly you can follow the show at
timcast IRL follow us on Instagram WE
Post Clips you can follow me personally
Twitter Instagram is a good place at
timcast Savannah you want to shout
anything out go follow me on Twitter I'm
back now guys at Sav underscore says
underscore or on YouTube Sav says thank
you Tim for having me it's been a fun
conversation I was really nervous but uh
you know we we got straight into the
government corruption and all the Nerf
just went away more to come members only
it's a love language I would say indeed
um anyway my name is lucrative my
YouTube channels we are change I did a
very interesting video about China
um and uh my main video was on Luke
uncensored.com specifically about Ron
DeSantis who is just doing incredible
things in Florida especially when it
comes to putting big Pharma in check
he's doing something absolutely
incredible maybe we could talk about it
on the after show with her sticker on my
shirt comes off and Lucan sensor.com is
the website hope to see you there thank
you guys out there for keeping me honest
keeping the crew honest keeping
everybody honest with uh things like
about the yazidis all that Savannah it's
great to see you again always good to
hear about your work next time you come
bring a white pill I'll bring a white
pill I'm not talking about MDMA but we
should all bring a white pill have a
white pill party if you know what I'm
talking about positive future growth
we'll talk about Solutions oh yeah good
to see you man what's happening bro
great episode thanks guys appreciate it
I'll see you guys in the comments I'm at
surge.com everywhere you can find me
we'll see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out cheers